i actually wash my phone
like once once a week you wash your
phone i don't know i just i i don't like
you it gets like
[ __ ] on it i don't really like it
i [ __ ] on my phone why do we talk about
[ __ ] as
like every time don't don't [ __ ] use
this use this
do it welcome to this episode of wait
which episode we will
i don't [ __ ] know what do you think
welcome to episode 43 i hope wait never
just don't mention that episode name
we've never mentioned an episode number
before i'm gonna do it i'm gonna [ __ ]
do it
43. welcome back to this episode of
trash taste and once again i'm with the
boys
who is joey who is gone that's the
answer to the boys
thank you i didn't realize yeah what is
this jeopardy
who is grant i've never watched jeopardy
before really yeah
actually why did they have to answer
like what is like grant
i don't know because because what the
instead of the question they give you
like an answer and then you the answer
is the question
like trivia grown man finds out what
japanese i've only seen like
out of context jeopardy tweet uh
jeopardy clips and i've just always
tried to figure out
why are they answering in questions i
feel like it's pretty easy to figure out
what's going on well now now that you've
explained it now of course it's gonna be
easy now they've explained they had to
tell me what was going on i was like i'm
guessing
based on you know what's going on i
can't really i can't recall the moment
in my life where i was like i need to
know how this game works
all right good job i can't even remember
the last time i watched a game show
it's just yeah yeah did you watch any
game shows growing up yeah i actually
watched quite a lot
we have quite good ones in the uk yeah
like how to be a millionaire that was
classic classic games you guys have like
uh deal or no deal
that was a what country originally made
that america america but we had like an
australian version
yeah the british one went for a long
time yeah we had like who's the host
no edmunds yeah have you seen the
american deal or no deal no
it's like it's like deal or no deal but
like it's
way more hollywoodized is it literally
just like the kitchen nightmares deal
where like kitchen nightmares usa is
like
boom you won't believe what happened and
then the uk one is like gordon's like
all right come on you gotta you're
acting
like it's it's just it's way bigger they
got like it you know
instead of just [ __ ] noel edmunds
like opening the briefcase or some or
something
they've got like the proper you know um
boxing ring chicks that like you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah like the models that
open up the briefcase you compared to
like the british version and it's just
it's just night and day wait does the
british version not have because i i
really see the boxes we have the boxes
oh because in australia
that we took the american thing we lined
up like 30 chicks can we explain what
deal and no deal is you're someone who
might not
okay basically like a contestant comes
on
um oh wait opens a bunch of briefcases
they have to get down to how do you even
wait so they get down to two
boxes don't they yeah okay so uh if i
remember correctly you have
i can't remember like 15 boxes or 15
briefcases
it's like 25. is that like a lot yeah
and i believe
you have to like you have to choose
random briefcases
and they get knocked out and then like
every briefcase has
a different amount of money in it and
when you choose that briefcase that
amount of money is knocked out of the
prize pool
and no but isn't it they they pick a
briefcase first and then
and they hang on to it but they don't
know what it is oh yeah yeah yeah
and then there's basically what they do
is the reason why
they don't just immediately skip to the
final one which you pick is because
along the way based on what you've
knocked out or got in so say you've
knocked out all the lower prize pools
like the 1000 pounds the 2000 they'll
offer you
deals yeah so the whole point of the
show is that you kind of want to knock
out all the small ones at first so that
they
might offer you a really generous deal
which yeah because your box might be
like the one that's left
yeah yeah it's it was always a really
fun game show and i really liked it but
in the uk i don't know if this is the
same in australia but like
all ages watch like the quiz shows like
the daily show yes yeah yeah
i just couldn't see like my my grandma
watching
like bikini models [ __ ] open up dude
my grandma was [ __ ] obsessed with
deal or no deal oh
my my great grandma too as well yeah she
was i don't know what it is watched it
every day
yeah wait but did you guys not have like
the
the the supermodels like without cases
no all game shows are like
unapologetically like just like chill
people
just doing like like for normally for
small amounts of money but yeah
but then on the opposite of the side of
the spectrum you guys have shows like
naked attraction yeah i mean i i don't
know i mean that's still a small scale i
would say because even like pointless
which has been like
uh if you don't know what pointless is
it's kind of hard to just [ __ ] google
it
i don't know i want to explain every
single game that we talk about um
pointless the prize pools only have like
1 000 pounds right
yeah which is really yeah which is like
to go on i think to go on you know
national tv it's like
for like what like 1 500 no 1 300
not really a lot if that's if you win
yeah yeah nothing if you don't
at least no deal had like i think the
prize pool the top price was like a
million dollars or something it's 250
250 000.
i don't know it pounds forward oh really
okay and australia was like a million
i think that's not too far off but i
mean you never saw anyone winning the
milk the price pools in general on the
uk
quiz shows are pretty small except for
like the big ones which are marketers
like the big ones
i think the biggest one we had was who
wants to be millionaire yeah that was
the yeah
that was the whole i mean i think that
was the biggest one anywhere right i'm
pretty sure
like they're probably like the uk
version was probably like the most
expensive just like [ __ ] why
why is our currency so god damn strong
you know
a million pounds a lot of times imagine
a japanese who wants to be a millionaire
we have that it's like did you just win
a million yen uh
like 10 grand i think uh wait what is it
again
ashley do you remember like how much
money is it for the japanese
who wants to be a millionaire i didn't
even know japan oh yeah never mind i'm
pretty sure it's a
million no it's 10 million yeah that
would make sense because we spoke about
it before i remember like to keshi's
castle
yeah like uh the japanese version i
think it was three million yen was the
prize yeah i thought for a game show
that [ __ ] hard
thirty thousand dollars doesn't seem
like a fair reward for a show that only
like five people ever won but in most
japanese
quiz shows yeah well it is about the
money but
when it is about the money the max you
get is like 10k
and usually and usually that's split
because like usually it's like a team
based
oh no i think so it's like you guys win
10k split between the five of you so
it's small and then after taxes so you
probably get
about a grand like what's your like
favorite australian or like american
i already liked family fortunes i don't
know i don't know what the american one
is but
family feuds i've seen like the american
like clips of the american one and that
seems
as fun if not even better than the
british version because like on the
american one i feel like they have like
more celebrities to choose from
exactly right exactly we only have like
a few very
giants yeah we had like les dennis which
i don't even remember what he was famous
for in the first place
because because like in america you have
like celebrities which normally are
known like the world over
yeah yeah that's just how it is but in
the uk you have like two tiers of
celebrities which are like
legit like massive celebrities known all
around the world like you know like
normally musical artists or like really
big actors and then the locals then you
have like the locally known ones which
are normally like just like
um the comedians are pretty good like
outside of that you have like someone
who's like
he said the a racist word on tv and made
a career out of it one time well
yes i mean okay i mean it's the same in
australia yeah i mean
in australia it's like you're either an
internationally known like star who's
hosting the show
or you're an australian comedian that
failed to like market themselves outside
of australia yeah yeah so he's just like
we'll give you a spot
you speak in australia we had okay we
had this one game show i think it was i
don't know if it was british first it's
called golden balls did you ever watch
this
oh yeah i didn't watch that yeah yeah i
know i know yeah yeah
teehee golden balls and i can't so what
would happen is that
they would get like five balls each and
they all had different amounts of money
in them right
and then they basically have to like
negotiate i think ah
no no so you could kick off sorry so no
no no um
like a football game no i i've seen i
haven't actually seen it but
i think we're thinking with the right
one where the last round the last round
is
it's the most it's the most interesting
one so you have a prize pool
and it's it's i think it's based on like
the prisoner's dilemma or something i'm
probably wrong on that but
so you have two people and you basically
have to
agree if you're going to share the prize
pool
um and or like okay so you have a
steal or share yeah all right you can
steal the entire prize pool or you can
share the prize pool
and if you share if if both people pick
share then you share the prize money
but if one person picks steel they get
the entire
amount of the prize oh okay but if both
people pick steal then no one gets
nobody gets surprised you saw like the
biggest pieces of [ __ ] on this show like
yeah you'd win the money but like that
really seems like a show to like expose
the world
it was brutal right because this tv show
[ __ ] loved it because they were like
bro
whatever you got to do to get this money
you ham it up so these people would do
like
massive sob stories to the person next
to you yeah right and they would believe
them
they'd be like man my kids you know they
need this thing real bad man they're
like you know they need this expensive
thing etcetera
and then and then they you know they
would do it and then they reveal like
they stole all the money yeah and
everyone's like okay sure you won 10
grand but yeah
and what cost what costs at what cost
you they go through their like entire
life story to be like
i uh i'm a devout christian i've given
to charity
i am the most honest person you could
ever meet in your life
they literally did a dion was just like
i'm going to reject humanity
to get this money i don't remember this
one guy i think i've seen the same clip
right was it which one which one was
there
the guy who just [ __ ] hacked like
social hacks of the game where he was
just like
look mate i'm gonna pick steel yeah and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's such
a such a like a five head move he
literally goes to the guy look i'm not
even gonna pretend
i'm going to pick steel okay and what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to share half the prize
money with you
once the game's over and the other guy's
was like no you you can't you can't do
that you got
you got you like no we're going to pick
share we're going to at least agree to
pick shad he's like no i'm picking steel
and you're gonna have to trust me
that i'm going to share the prize money
after the after after the show ends and
like the other guy asked the host is
this allowed is this actually allowed
and the host goes
whatever happens after the show we can't
guarantee you know
so he's like he gets shanked that's your
issue yeah yeah so so he's like well i'm
gonna pick steel as well then and he's
like fine if you pick steel
we're both gonna lose the money but the
only chance you're gonna have to gain
money
is by picking share right such a [ __ ]
five head moves like this
but at the end he didn't pick steel he
picked cher
so both of them got the prize money in
the end oh [ __ ] wow and i was just like
dude this this this guy this guy is the
main protagonist of the [ __ ] universe
i'll be the bad guy so that everyone can
win like i just
i just watched like irl code kiosk right
in front of me
this is what i saw right here i i saw
like i swear i don't know if this was
like a popular clip i remember one time
the guy like literally came into the
show
because there's four contestants at the
start i believe he was literally just
right from the start being like i'm a
steal
i'm going to steal no matter what life
and then he stole and then he didn't get
anything see the person also stole wow
so it was like the same thing
but like small brain version where he
was he was like
i'm gonna steal to everyone i was like
yeah we know i'm not giving you anything
so am i god imagine you you wait for
months right you go through all the
interviews and [ __ ] you get on the show
finally you have a chance of winning
money and some [ __ ] [ __ ]
immediately just said to everyone i'm
going to ruin the show for all of you
i don't give a [ __ ] you'd be like well
[ __ ] what am i supposed to do
that's like the that's like the what's
the [ __ ] the thing uh the the
millionaire hot seat
thing as well did you have those no we
don't have that i don't think okay
because like
i don't know if it wasn't we definitely
had it in australia though so there's
like you know there's like who wants to
be a millionaire which is just like a
one-on-one thing
there's this other version of it called
millionaire hot seat which
is basically it's one game of
millionaire but then there's like
four other people in basically like
sitting on the benches
waiting for the person to [ __ ] up and if
one person gets the answer wrong
then it goes to the next person from
where they started that's pretty cool
and so
i remember i saw this clip which is like
you start off with five people
right and uh they got to i don't know i
was like the 2000 you know not even
halfway up kind of thing
and i guess it was like a really hard
question so
the first guy gets a wrong and he's like
oh [ __ ] all right whatever see you later
next person comes along fully confident
being like well he basically just got
rid of one of the answers for me
i got this and not only does he get it
wrong but then
the next person during 50 50 he also
gets it wrong
so the fourth person comes up is like
so there's only one answer remaining um
i think it's this one
it's like you're correct but like
imagine waiting
sitting on the benches all that time to
just come up and be like
thank you for giving me this money thank
you for the free money thank you for the
free money
jkc yeah i'm trying to remember what
else was that the weakest link
german the weakest link yeah like what's
his name uh was it phil or dan which one
of them was on the weakest link
oh were they yeah one of them yeah one
of them was on the weakest link
what's the weakest link oh it's just
it's just not going anywhere is it i
don't think so it was this really
popular daytime british tv show where we
had this like really like she was famous
for being like [ __ ]
basically okay because that was her
whole character was that she was there i
remember her name
um and she was just a quiz show and
basically like it would just keep going
and
asking questions and you basically like
at the end of the question the round
they'd ask eight people you have to vote
someone off and it was normally the
person who was letting the team down
because
if you got a question wrong you like
ruined the streak and it's like a video
game where more bonus
more streaks so if someone gets a
question wrong
they ruin it and you get less money yeah
and you if you
so like as it's going around so if i get
one right i get 100 points then you get
200 then 400.
and someone has to like say bank so that
the points get saved
so the stream can keep going until
someone saves it so if you're the one
who's like i'm gonna get the
the big boy question and then you [ __ ]
it up and lose the money that everyone
just earned
yeah you're probably gonna get voted off
right right but then like there was a
meta game behind it as well because if
you are too good
then people then then people would just
like gang up in you and vote you off
because
they would have won the best chance of
winning right right you were on the game
show right
yeah and then there was a that's
probably and i think i can't wish one it
was dan or phil one of them was on it
before they became a youtuber oh wow
yeah it's really good you should watch
it
they're like uh the hosts are just like
roasting them that sounds fun it's just
pretty it's really endearing watching
someone before they were a youtuber like
do it like
i don't know it's really fun i've always
wanted to be on like trivia shows like
yeah
yeah i mean i think i'd like to go on a
show that has like literally that is
just like hey
this is just a game show just go up and
do it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
no no no no no no no no hey play this
character no just let me just [ __ ] go
on
myself like is there like uh what's
really how a game show is still going on
yeah they are i think like it's like i'd
like to think that most game shows are
the complete opposite of like the talent
shows
yeah yeah because the talent shows are
just heavily scripted
narratives yeah yeah yeah yeah all this
stuff i think we just don't know because
we don't watch tv
yeah we i just stopped watching tv so i
actually have no [ __ ] idea
anymore yeah yeah me too there was this
youtuber now who's uploading
um he entered uh an american talent show
that i'd never heard of
um i think he's called reckless ben on
youtube and he's like
he he basically signed up for this thing
and then wore secret glasses
while he's on it so now he's uploading
videos of him
behind the scenes and his narration is
really [ __ ] funny
and uh yeah now they're just like
threatening him to
take the video yeah of course yeah and
he's uploading videos be like i'm not
gonna take it down
this is the next video i'm taking it
down
it's right it's really interesting it's
just really living up to his name yeah
cause he's just like
he's in it and he's just narrating
really stupid and he's just like a
complete clown in like
the best way possible yeah yeah it's
really interesting you should watch
these youtube videos i didn't sell it
very well i feel like
i still want to explain too much you
should go watch them it's pretty really
really
underrated yeah no one's watching these
videos they have like 80k 100k
which is that's that's still decent
amounts well like as crazy as this
a lot bigger but i know it's is it like
even a big kind of
exposure that hey this is kind of faked
and no but it's just
all scripted it's really fun just seeing
like a producer go up to him and be like
no not now oh hey this is your
like oh like you know like when the
crowd's cheering yeah yeah like he shows
like the video footage of like what's
the show see that he cuts to what
what's happening to him and it's just
him in the middle of a giant stage and
there's nothing
like no noise or anything
i think there's a big difference between
just like hearing and knowing that it's
rigged versus actually
seeing that you know like all those
talent shows as well have like on
on-site therapists because of like how
like brutal the schedule it's like some
of them uh in like
america's got talent had to like sit
around for like 19 hours
to like wait to practice [ __ ] jesus
so they had on-site therapists
and they would like there was like cases
where they're injecting them with like
vitamins and stuff to keep them awake
during these shows what the [ __ ] yeah
and then obviously you know these
contracts you sign which have come out
before for like x factor in the uk
yeah yeah it's kind of horrible yeah and
my god like some of them i swear it was
x factor uk where
you literally sign away your rights to
anything you've ever done online
yeah and any right anything you do in
future yeah like if you became a
youtuber they own it
like you can't do without their
permission yeah it's [ __ ]
it's not i get why they do because they
want to cover their ass but they go
like so beyond where it's like this is
kind of like this is going to have just
agreed exploitative but like people want
their five minutes of fame right that's
right and it's like what are you gonna
do get five minutes of fame yourself no
i don't think you don't think so
what do you do build a career good one
good one
not without my help not without simon
cowell [ __ ] breathing down your
throat i don't think so
jesus christ i'll tell you what uh
sydney's been watching recently she's
been like she's gone off the true crime
for a bit and she's just
yeah she's now turned over to uh trash
tv uh reality trash tv
she's been watching 90 day fiance bro i
could just feel the script
when i'm watching that show like you can
tell like the producers have made them
do like two
three takes [ __ ] it's awful i can't
stand it i watched like one whole season
of it and it was just like
they just repeat you watching one whole
season i watched the whole i'm impressed
yeah i don't know i really don't know i
didn't enjoy half of it either i was
watching it and it's just like
they go in [ __ ] circles they'll be
like that so they'll meet up and they'll
be like
yeah it's kind of weird but we just love
each other and then there'll just be
like red flags right from the start
yeah like yeah he asked me to paypal i'm
like 10 grand you know he doesn't want
to have kids i want to have kids
but you know i think love has a way and
it's like atheists like love
drama right yeah [ __ ] genius because
i i feel like watching 90 day fiance
right
i lose brain cells watching this at
least
like i imagine what if it aired like on
twitch or something
i think it would be a [ __ ] excellent
experience if something like that aired
on twitch
huh like unscripted no i mean just like
watching with like the twitch chat
you see all the reactions that's like
part of the fun fun thing the worst part
about watching it
like in seasons was like yeah without
the youtube comments
90 day fiance is like 14 less enjoyable
yeah yeah
the best comments was like making sure
that everyone agrees with you
who's the bigger [ __ ] yeah yeah
exactly it's it's like
literally like the a real life version
of ah am i the [ __ ] you know it's
you know you you go that see the spicy
drama but watching it by yourself
i feel is just you lose half of the
enjoyment out of it how did you sit
through like a normal episode of that
oh it was hard because like i watched
because obviously like like every
anybody i got
into through the [ __ ] ed and rose
clips right that went around
me too so i was just like oh you know if
the clips are this good then i'm pretty
sure the entire episode is good
it's hot well just like it's such a drag
it is it is one of those tv shows where
like the clip is the best way to watch
it yeah yeah yeah yeah
watching this was like brutal like none
of these couples are like good people
they're all just like the worst people
yeah
doing the shittiest things to each other
and then being surprised when none of it
works
and it's like it is it is horrible i
mean i mean like it's it's trash tv but
i mean you know why you're watching it
right
no one's watching it to be like maybe
this situation will work out
and this girl's like you know this this
guy who's on his 10th marriage you know
and i've only known for three months i
don't know if he really loves me
it is literally it is like
someone has made like a playbook of like
the worst setups to relationships
like there's always like someone who
can't speak the other person's language
so they just can't communicate most of
the times and it's like it's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's just loading up an episode right
now apparently so what are they talking
about there's like
there was like one where it was like the
girl's like 18 and the guy's 46 and has
two kids and i'm like that just sounds
like a bad idea
yeah it was like yeah it was like that
on someone else yeah it was like um
was the other one there was like these
this was one of them i think it was like
oh he was like a south african guy
and the other one was like an american
like uh she was like super activist
and stuff and like he was just kind of
like the most laid-back man on earth was
like yeah yeah wherever wherever
and she was just like i need you to know
that i care about these things and she
was psychotic
and like watching her like behave around
this guy was like awful
and i was just like this is terrible
this is awful why is he doing this how
much is he getting paid
yeah that's what i'm wondering it's like
plc like i need to know no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no it's tlc so
they're definitely paying attention
are you sure they're getting paid
they're getting paid pennies like
because
i feel like i hope they're getting paid
because if they're not getting paid i
don't know why they're putting up with
half of this [ __ ]
yeah it is i'm pretty sure tlc pays all
of the people that they have
sure but yeah but like i use the word
paid very loosely like they're probably
getting paid scraps for that [ __ ]
yeah it's just like it's like i'm
watching this and i'm like how much
would you have to pay me
because you know that uh you know the
rose the the filipino
girl she's like a youtuber now yeah i
saw sure
so it's just like you probably got paid
[ __ ] all but
hey you got a youtube career now i guess
i don't know you haven't followed
the rap situation where if the other
side is just so
goddamn awful it makes you look amazing
yeah yeah yeah
and i did her solid it's it's it's
always weird for me watching american
reality tv show versus
british reality tv show because i feel
like british reality tv show is like
so much more toned down than americans
like
i think i think when i think of british
reality tv shows
the peak that comes to me is something
like come dine with me that's
pretty good or like uh what's the other
one that that [ __ ] guy does where you
just come up to him at a table and he's
buy [ __ ] off you for like a hundred quid
was the antique hunters or something oh
antiques roadshow
anti-road show is that is that it oh i
like that i like that
i've been on the air for like i don't
know how long and it's just fun to watch
people to bring in some things i'll give
you [ __ ] 20 quid for it yeah it's
like the [ __ ] you know like porn
stars right but like legitimately
more legit than that yeah yeah come down
with me it's probably
probably the best british reality show i
think i enjoy it
one of my favorite trash reality tv
shows i can't remember the name
but the concept is they take this couple
who you know doesn't have a lot of money
but
are wanting but want to get married oh
my god i want to get married it's
[ __ ]
lovely yeah not cheap as weddings that's
the australian is that
is that the australian australian voters
and they get like they give them 10k
to sort out this wedding right now oh
it's uh uh and like
the bride has no control she she doesn't
know anything and it's all up to the guy
lucky's obsessed with that show it was a
bbc three show yeah yeah yeah and uh who
called the bride or something like
something like something like that who
wants the bride who wants to write
something like that
but it's such a it was such a good
concept in my opinion because like 10k i
feel like is
just the right amount of money to be
able to make a wedding happen but
not enough to make everything you want
out of a wedding happened
that's pretty genius yeah it's it's
ingenious and like making the guy do it
as well
yeah i mean you don't need producers
right you just sit there and follow the
guy
if he does nothing that's fantastic
content yeah he's like and
they must be fully aware of it too
because they always shoot they always
choose to use the 10k in the
worst [ __ ] we should have done that
with god's wedding yes
because the guys in the show right the
first thing they do it's like call up
the crew
yeah and they call it like their boy
they call up their boys and they're like
and then like the main guy will be
[ __ ] clueless
that one friend is like i really don't
think you should you know hire
inflatable dinosaurs for your wedding
that seems like a bad idea
like no no i got this that's why you're
waiting there's always like there's
always that there's either the guy who
like there was never a guy who got it
like 100 right because yeah yeah
there was a guy who was like pretty
close and then like did a modest attempt
and there was just the other type of guy
that was like
i'm gonna do [ __ ] star wars themed
wedding
my favorite one is the one where like
the the the groom like
decides to get married in like a pig
barn oh yes yeah i've seen this one like
they go to like a
the dead is gonna like a farm with like
a [ __ ] muddiest
i i think it's like but you love pigs
i think i saw one where the guy like
hosted the wedding in a cave
like a proper an actress okay yes you're
not caving
yeah yeah i mean that's that's badass
but then like not in the nutty buddy
like he knew that the bride's mum was
claustrophobic
so the bride's not match he couldn't
attend like the wedding ceremony because
he was like standing outside the cave
that's [ __ ] big brain that's so big
brain
yeah so uh my in-laws hate boats so i
decided let's get on the cruise
i mean as someone who's like planning a
wedding now it's it's it's great for me
because i'm just like
i i see the stress that people that
people can make a survey to like
sydney's family so what are your fears
what are you afraid of like zooms like
what
it's like my favorite moment is always
when they try to pick the dress
it's like it's not even like a little
bit wrong it's always the complete
opposite of what the bride picks
it's literally like m123 and have a
breakdown have a mental breakdown right
now start crying start telling
the wedding's over that's literally how
it looks this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn guys we talk about [ __ ] a
lot on this podcast right
we do this we do we yes now don't you
want to [ __ ] with the privacy of the
bathroom door locked of course i do well
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door so why would we want to
do that that just sounds
barbaric and i will not stand for it i'm
being told that internet service
providers like comcast or verizon know
every single website you visit that's
really interesting information because
i've also heard that isps can sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who then use your data to target
you expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device
and the internet so your online activity
can't be seen by
anyone it's as easy as closing the
bathroom door simply fire up the app and
press
one button and i use this all the time
when i'm watching anime as certain
websites don't let you watch from japan
and trust me it's [ __ ] easy oh yeah
what devices you use it on
every single device i have my pc my
phone probably my refrigerator soon when
it gets installed not only that but it's
rated number one by cnet wired the verge
and other creditable sources and
it's actually quite cheap per month
expressvpn has been a game changer for
me because i cannot tell that i'm even
connected to your vpn there's no losses
in speed whatsoever so what are you
waiting for secure your online activity
today by visiting expressvpn.com
trash taste that's expressvpn.com
trash taste and you can get an extra
three months free go to expressvpn.com
trash taste back to the episode i would
i would you know even if i got
like paid on top of doing the wedding
because i'm assuming the
the like kind of the reason why people
apply for that show is you get a free
wedding right yeah yeah
but like man organizing a wedding seems
like one of the
the easiest things to get wrong
like just i thought about this yeah yeah
i thought about this and i was like god
damn just the like
because you know like all right you have
friends right but like not every friend
you want to come to your wedding right
so that must be so [ __ ] awkward
deciding like
you're you're a good enough friend but
like i don't know if
you're like good enough for the wedding
i can barely organize a boys night out
let alone
[ __ ] also like you have like how many
friends do you have right and like where
do you draw the line who's close enough
how do you decide
is it like a mutual thing you're like no
i don't like ted like what winning
politics is like definitely i think
it's so difficult my my cousin went
through it as well and it's just
it's ah there's there's a lot that goes
into a wedding that
i like i i have no interest i didn't
obviously it's
it's like trying to plan a wedding
yourself is hard enough trying to plan a
wedding
internet like when you're not in the
country yeah and also during like covert
here
[Music]
this this is this is like not even like
hard mode this is like dark souls no
no like there's so many things that
can like that can [ __ ] up as well i love
how i love that nowadays whenever
anything is like extremely hard the
first thing you think of
dark souls no hit nothing's harder than
that
yeah i mean it's stressful but it's it's
rewarding
yeah it must be i think i mean is it
going on i mean it's rewarding
yes yes it's rewarding until like
it will be rewarding once it actually
finishes right yeah and everything goes
smooth i mean i mean like the planning
parts some of it's better than the
others like i remember like my favorite
moment so far has been
actually going to the venue and just
being like yeah this is the place this
is the place that's an amazing feeling
everything up to that like searching
through about 50 catalogues of possible
places and driving to about 10 different
places
places and being like uh do i want to
settle on this
i don't know can i see myself getting
married in a barn or a cave
or whatever in japan it's like crazy how
like [ __ ] seriously they take this
oh yeah oh it's it's eve it's like in
asia
they're like we think there's like
wedding politics in western weddings no
in asia it's a [ __ ] statement
yeah right and i hate that i i
absolutely hate that because there's
so many unspoken rules that are changing
the amount that they must spend on
weddings here
oh it's nice yeah it's insane if you go
to like any like fancy hotel
in japan like you just cause you know if
you go there for like a lunch or
something you'll see that like the
wedding planning rooms are like
full with people yeah and like those
prices don't seem cheap
they seem real expensive like 50k on a
wedding i'm like what
yeah i went i went to one of my friend's
weddings from university and
he did it in japan in tokyo and the
inside of this venue looked like a
[ __ ] mini disneyland
like it was there was like a castle and
like a [ __ ] fountain and this like
massive
completely white church i'm like how
much money did you just yeah
like what amount of money is too much to
spend on a wedding i get that it's a
special day but there has to be a limit
well like a special day is like
ridiculous
there was like 300 people at this
wedding yeah because like nobody knows
300 people
sorry i don't even know if i have to
even have that many friends on facebook
let alone i don't know
do you like families asking like hey can
my like family friend of a friend
come did you get like that because i
feel like i'd be like no i don't [ __ ]
know them no
in japan it's like the wedding politics
extends to like
you have to work to invite people yeah
yeah because because it's all about the
face right so
like in in thailand you have to invite
your family your family friends your
work colleagues like basically everyone
i mean close colleagues yeah
you know yeah they've got actual message
inviting my boss
yeah and another thing about thai
weddings
shut up bailey which is why like me and
cindy decided to have our wedding in the
uk so we didn't have to worry about you
know that that side
[ __ ] yeah but like it it's a
customary entire wedding
as well that the groom has to give money
you have to have to give like a certain
amount of money
to the bride's like family
like bother to accept or something um
what era are we in you buying her is
that like an extra stab i don't know i
mean
how much is your daughter yeah i give
you two goats oh it's like an ocean
like what is this i mean that's like
[ __ ] russian like mother right he's
like i give you two goats
this feels like this feels like an extra
step to like auction you know
yeah i mean it's something that i don't
agree with and i've seen like some of my
family members doing i'm just like
yeah i don't know i don't care i kind of
don't agree with this is that where it
comes from like where does that come
from that
honestly i have no idea does it come
from something more sinister like what
you've been doing
i mean i'm not i'm not sure how the
custom started because
you know like it's it's something that
i've attended thai weddings and i've
seen happen
um i've i've never kind of asked where
where where this where this came from i
just kind of was just like
yeah i don't think i want to do that so
you guys just kind of died did you buy
mom
i mean like she pressed i did it
i mean it's my bargain
the same customary where it's like the
bride's dad is expected to play for the
wedding
and i'm just like no that shouldn't be
the case either yeah right
like it's it's it's to me a wedding
there's
there's so many customaries to weddings
that revolve around money that i just
don't understand i guess because like
maybe
i mean that was common that's pretty
common in the west still right that the
uh the other person the
bridegroom the bride's parents will pay
but i mean it's understandable when
marriage used to be way younger like 21.
yeah yeah yeah
i get it then because you don't have any
money but now people getting married at
what like
27 30 30 so it's like you know i mean
you probably should have your own money
by then you know like yeah should be
planning a wedding
you're unemployed at 30. maybe
you're just dissing yourself yeah i mean
just saying
i'm just sorry for that guy who just
like you know had like five children and
all of them ended up being daughters and
he's like come on come on son son
son oh my god it's like the uh like
aging population like pyramid thing
right
it won't bite you now it'll bite you
later
yeah because isn't it like i remember i
saw like this i don't remember it was a
vice documentary or some kind of
documentary on youtube where like
i forgot which country it was somewhere
in the middle east where like they still
have the tradition of like
wife napping where it's like they they
did
i forgot which country it was but i
remember i saw this documentary
and there's this tradition quote-unquote
tradition
where guys if they find a girl
that they find attractive and they see
as wife material
some of them will actually like dead-ass
kidnap them
like in broad daylight take them back to
their parents place
and the girl is then forced to get
married to this guy
what is this like [ __ ] real life
pokemon sounds like runescape this
sounds like runescape
and like and like traditionally the girl
can't decline it
really yeah so like that she has to get
married in and and there's always
and this documentary i saw is like it's
so [ __ ] disturbing because there's
these girls who are literally just
breaking down while they get the veil
put on top of them and [ __ ] and it's
just
it's [ __ ] oh i i i wish i could
remember the
the name of the documentary as i was
like there was this thing i don't
remember though
just look it up if you look up like wife
napping i think it's called trash chase
podcast early onset outside
which is [ __ ] forgetting we forget
everything here we can't remember
anything we're [ __ ] useless
this thing i saw on the internet i
vaguely remember that but there's one
detail i remember that i want to talk
about now and just share to the world
one episode we were talking about like
uh how
how very rarely like anime uses english
like songs in their openings and endings
and we're bringing up all these titles
and we're like i'm sure there's other
ones we don't know all the titles are
like
jojo hello you know that one show you're
all obsessed about
i just forget everything all the time i
feel like when you put on the spot
oh yeah especially when you put on the
spot like you're recording and you're
recording it's just
never take our word on anything that's
that's just the golden rule never take
out one on it we are not liable for
anything that we
yeah um right you know what i don't
forget though
because it happened to me right
yesterday just stop by the police
what do you mean what did you do a
criminal illegal activity that you did
being
wise i'm being a minority for once
wait what did you do nothing i was so i
was literally nothing
so like i was literally like okay so i'm
coming up the escalator to like
you know because in japan you have to
like ding out of the gates right yeah so
coming up to the escalator to go through
the gates and
there's like two pylons two sets and i'm
so i'm coming at the escalators i'm
going to go
forward to him being out and literally
hiding behind the pylon as a police
officer and when i pass him i've got
headphones on i've got to like cap on so
like
maybe i'll [ __ ] dodgy i don't know
but literally when i pass this guy i see
like in my corner my eyes gotta jump
into action just immediately come up to
me and stop me and i'm like [ __ ] what
what have i done dude and i'm like what
what's wrong and i'm like oh so i i
won't say anything in japanese i'll just
translate it all yeah
he's like oh where are you going and i'm
like um
just going home you know just chilling
out why what's up you're like oh really
cool cool can i see all your cards so
you have like a
foreigners card right yeah which or by
law you always have to have
this uh foreigner what's it called
yeah yeah yeah and he asked me if like
japanese okay i'm like yeah
i can i speak a little bit and luckily
like everything he said i understood so
it's good
and he was like oh okay and by the way
like my like my train is in like
i think like four minutes i'm like come
on man come on yeah keep it up keep it
up so he looks at my cardio and it says
like oh i'm an entertainer
he's like oh cool cool what do you do
i'm like oh i say uh say you which means
like voice actor
yeah yeah he's like oh say and i'm like
yeah yeah like and then he's like oh
eco sensei so like japanese teacher and
i'm like
what i literally just told you why would
it be entertainer
i'm just sitting there like ah no no no
like like yeah
like say say you're like mc tall like
yeah yeah commercials games it's like oh
games i'm like yeah yeah games
he's like what games and i was just like
i was like what do you want me to like
you're gonna look it up like what do you
want so i'm like oh it's in english it's
in english and he's like oh
deadass right he goes oh do you play
apex he's like
40 maybe 50. dead ass asked me if i play
apex i'm just sitting here like laughing
so i'm like [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] you not i go i say i say yeah
i'm diamond rank
and he goes
like two minutes two minutes and i
trained in two minutes and um
he's like oh cool you're from the uk i'm
like yeah yeah from the uk uk so it's
like
and at this point i feel like oh okay
i'm kind of like i know he's not gonna
lie it's just me yeah yeah
he's just talking about yeah sounds like
he's just looking for a friend right now
i don't know why he's talking to me he
doesn't say why he stopped me he doesn't
say anything
like that maybe he he was one of the
japanese dudes you played hey
maybe he he just looks at you and he's
like this guy gives off gamer energy
i'm gonna stop him i wonder if that guy
plays apex
and so yeah so i'm i'm like that he's
like i think i'm from the uk
yes where i'm from so you can speak good
english then no no i thought this is all
in general
he can speak he was nihongo yeah like
luckily
everything he said i either understood
or understood enough of what he's saying
right
to form figure out what he's like he
said something about
something going to uk something
something marriage and i'm like ah and i
said like honeymoon in like broke like
katakana like uh honeymoon
yeah oh hi hi so he told me that he went
to
the uk and he loved it he said ano orki
ben
that he liked buckingham palace he said
the japanese word for palace
yeah which is cute yeah he said that
something you then [ __ ]
dumb queue there yeah he said buckingham
cute queue then i'm like i'm pretty sure
he's saying buckingham palace
i don't like kid it's beautiful listen
it's beautiful it's like yeah yeah yeah
he's like
yeah i was like laughing i'm like i
don't want to laugh though she's a
police officer
why are you laughing because you guys
know what bing means right
what it means [ __ ]
saying i didn't know that it's like dead
ass means
giant [ __ ] i mean that's pretty [ __ ]
it's pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
big [ __ ] it's the big [ __ ] i thought
because i thought the word for [ __ ] was
uncle
no bang is another word for yeah so yeah
and then he was just like yeah i go to
paris i'm like oh yeah you like wine
it's like yeah me and my wife love wine
i'm like
cool cool i like wine too he's like all
right yeah you can go now and i'm like
thanks man thanks make me miss my
[ __ ] train
ten minutes so you so you're dead i just
bonded with a police officer over
apex yeah luckily it was nice but like
it's pretty like alerting when you first
stop you and i'm like why are you
stopping yeah right why are you stopping
me
and then someone told me uh they were
like yeah apparently there's like um
some police officers like quotas of like
people they have to stop
oh really it makes sense certain areas
they've just got so little work to do
here right so and they're normally told
to i guess they're getting paid to do
something this is like the least like
xenophobic way of like saying this but
i've i've been told i don't know if this
is true that some police officers are
told to stop
uh foreigners to practice their english
i mean that makes sense that makes sense
but it
feels wrong like if that happened in
another country
or i would be like yeah that's [ __ ] up
that's not right yeah yeah but i mean
you know like at least they're nice
about it though right yeah i just don't
like that they asked like my id
like i don't know someone about that
feels weird i guess they check my
colleagues
there's never a way where a policeman
asks for your id and you don't at least
sweat a little
yeah yeah right like i'm like the
audible like swallow like this is
literally like
white guy gets like discriminated first
time in his life
pov like this is like the story right
so this is what it feels like to be a
minority [ __ ] oh god fish is [ __ ] up
i'm kidding i know it's [ __ ] bad yeah
but like yeah i mean it's happened a few
times but it's because it's happened at
like 10 p.m i was like
you know for some reason when it happens
at night it feels like way more like
whoa
and i'm like why are you stopping anyone
else i'm the only i'm the only
non-japanese you shouldn't have told
this story on trash days you could have
easily made up
i got my first racist experience in
japan
my video i'll do it i'll do it on a live
stream so the clip can come out before
this part
yeah good idea gonna get the actual
brain yeah yeah i just like i just
i started cracking up so much when he
asked me when i played apex i was like
oh my god oh my god i was like you can't
make this [ __ ] up like
i knew when i was going to tell the
story you're going to be like that's
[ __ ] no it actually i wish i [ __ ]
this is like this
i was like this is too unreal that he
just literally just asked me if i play
apex
but i literally like don't shout about
it it's like everyone but it's really
it's really popular in japan sorry
it's massive in japan what are like the
biggest games in japan
what genre of games like what in first
person shooters i think it's like apex
right now
like because it's possible online games
big in japan even yeah yeah there's a
huge scene for it like
apex right now is massive because also
shockingly because the v youtubers that
are playing it was popular before that
yeah but the beach
ninja signs propelled the [ __ ] out of it
yeah yeah yeah because like when we
moved to japan i think is when
pub g was big right pubg was big but i
think apex either just released or
released like a while back and they were
doing a huge push for it
because i the month where we moved here
every single ad i got was apex legends
really in japan yeah everything was and
um
i thought wow that's kind of weird
because it's kind of like a dead game in
like the west
at least it was i feel like it
flip-flops and whether it's popular or
not yeah
what even counts as a dead game anymore
right overwatch i'd say
that's because overwatch 2's coming out
so they're just like abandoned
um but like you know i mean i not a dead
game but like not
in like the public discourse is what i
would consider like
yeah when people when people say dead
game i think that's what they mean like
it's not
like no one plays it like the main
population is talking about it or not
right yeah yeah like it's not like
you you know you're not expected to have
some general knowledge about it because
you're not expected to have a police
officer come up to you
do you play overwatch do you play
overwatch
who do you mean who's your overwatch
player right like you tankers like they
don't really
i'm gonna sound like such a [ __ ]
boomer right now like what even are the
popular games right now
right because because like when i think
coffee all that
when i when i think popular game i think
you know whatever the fad is right now
like
among us and four guys well i think
after the among us kind of like settled
it definitely became a bit more variety
like tends to be quite a lot like uh
valheim's picking up steam which is kind
of like a reimagining of runescape
almost
all i've heard valheim is is just like
minecraft but better graphics
oh i heard runescape with like mixed
with minecraft oh really
um apex has obviously had a really big
resurgence yeah
really good numbers like a lot of big
streamers are getting back into it yeah
yeah i think valerian's still doing
pretty well
leagues obviously league league's just
always up there i think csgo is still
the same thing where it's always been
like kind of like you know the scrappy
little underdog because i
i think the thing is like i look at the
top watch games on twitch and they're
normally like the games that i just
never end up playing
yeah so i don't actually i i never
actually know what and what everyone
ends up playing or what's kind of
popular right now um
i don't know we haven't had any massive
games recently after a manga we haven't
really had anything that's
stolen the spotlight i don't yeah i
could be wrong
i think the last time i spoke about
games i got things very wrong people
gave me [ __ ]
that's fair enough go ahead i feel like
the whole idea of like
you know like the most popular game
nowadays is a little bit blurred
just because like anyone can i feel like
it's like they're gonna be the top
games yeah yeah like chess has had
already big resurgence obviously yeah
balloons tower defense six man i'm
telling you man it's coming
everyone's playing it man before it gets
better
fortnite obviously is just fortnite i
don't know like i feel like a lot of
games are just kind of like settled
yeah we haven't really had anything to
shake i mean i remember for the longest
time we're in the league community where
everyone's just like
yo league's dying league's dying it's
it's it's
yeah it's never gonna well it's never
gonna die um it got it plateaued but i
feel like there's a difference between
something plateauing and something kind
of like and also the league of
viewership has been like pretty
consistent just because of the plateaus
doesn't mean it's
you know yeah no no i mean i mean league
is still like you know you can still
easily
support a billion dollar company people
are playing it so you know
but it's like it's like is it in public
discourse right or not i usually i
usually chalk up to
whether a game is popular if like
minecraft is like like small
like the younger generation of playing
it true like you know
like if you go to like a primary school
and they're talking about apex and
fortnite and minecraft then it's like
okay this is like the big games right
now yeah it's funny man i mean my mom
was telling me she works in primary
school she told me like one kid got like
really bullied because um
he was like bad is it for tonight no
wasn't there uh there was a story
skin as well yeah there was a story in
japan where a kid got bullied because he
had the default skin fortnite
serves him right wow i mean i think
we've talked about this before but i've
heard the same story as well
um but like i think minecraft is
definitely probably the biggest i'd say
minecraft's still the biggest
minecraft's just a juggernaut at this
point it's not going anywhere since
since our last stream i've been like
should i play minecraft sure should i
[ __ ] should i play minecraft
it's dead it's so relaxing if we all
play minecraft you guys got to try apex
we should do that we should do like a
like a game cultural cross
cross-pollination
we should do that come on it's what the
people want god
you're just never going to give up on
this song because i know if you guys try
it you'll have a good time
yeah i think you will i think every
person who ever offered me an fps game
said
the same thing it's because this is with
the boys i heard it about fortnight i
heard it about overwatch
i've already talked about this we'll
give it a shot we'll give it a shot
we'll try it guys don't worry
i'll convince them so i guess switching
gears did you guys hear about this
like deep fake story that happens i
think today
or yesterday so yesterday for us but it
would be like three weeks for the
audience yeah three weeks three weeks
for the audience facts may come out i
mean yeah i i have not
like with deep fake becoming like such a
big thought like a bigger thing now
so i uh i can't we're gonna go back to
this
i can't remember every detail of the
story but i think the main gist of it
was
there was his mom and she had a daughter
who was on the cheerleading squad
we get maylene to check the story while
we're talking about it yeah just google
deep fake news that'll be like a top
story
so i believe there was mom who had a
daughter who was on the cheerleading
squad
um and there were other girls on that
cheerleading squad
and for some reason she wanted the
she wanted to kick these other girls off
of the squad
right so what she did is she made some
deep fakes
for like of the other girls like smoking
yeah like smoking drinking
doing doing like bad illegal activities
or whatever right right
and i think threatening them with it
right or like i can't remember if she
threatened them or she sent them
straight to them
sure how she did it but i think they
they saw it and the reason why
it got even found out was because they
took it to the police yeah
yeah and how she got found out was she
used the fake number
she used like this internet service that
gave them a gave her a fake number
but that didn't hide her ip address
and that's the only reason she found out
sponsored by you know
i don't think she would have got caught
if she was sponsored by it
i don't think our sponsor would be very
happy now that's why we're not going to
mention any names
yeah but i mean i i saw it and i'm just
like well i can't believe they actually
took
this long or something like this to
happen you know the most unbelievable
part of the story is there's a mum out
there that's tech savvy enough
because that's what i thought mike you i
don't even think my mum knows what a
[ __ ] deep fake is
let alone had it she doesn't even know
how to search for files on windows
i'm actually impressed her mum knew how
to make a difference because i'm
impressed
what i'm impressed that mom knew how to
do a deep fake but i'm even
more like because okay um i'm
not sure if any of this is confirmed so
i'm going to put out
a disclaimer that we could be totally
wrong this could be please check this
out do your own research yeah but
by the time this comes out all right all
right
i'll cut the story awhile by the time
this come out comes out everything might
be confirmed
this might all have been like false
information or it would it might have
just been like
claims but at the time of recording we
don't know if it's real or not
but these are what the allegations are
right uh and the allegation was that she
did this because
the daughters on the cheerleading squad
she stopped hanging out with her
daughter
and so she she wanted to get them kicked
off because of that and i'm just
thinking
if someone's this petty to be this crazy
how dare you are not friends how did she
manage to figure out how to do deep
fakes
they all she also sent them anonymous
messages tying them to
that they should you know end their own
lives as well to the these kids
the mom did that the mom did that what
the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
how this is something some people are
not supposed to be scared this is so
like cartoon villain like it's so absurd
that someone could be this
[ __ ] oh my god yeah but
i mean i saw that and i'm just thinking
my first thought was i'm
one i'm surprised that it took this long
for something like this to happen right
this mug shot looks like she's tore
someone's face off
oh my god she looks like a disney
villain doesn't it yeah
like maleficent just ripped someone's
face off and stitched it that's like
should i say that it's probably too
going too far isn't it that's like
that's like i shouldn't [ __ ] you
telling kids to watch that actually it
looks like she's wearing someone else's
face oh my god
you know there's more concerning about
that that was someone's parent
yeah holy [ __ ] imagine being raised by
someone like that
holy [ __ ] that kid's gonna be [ __ ]
but apparently the kid knew nothing like
the mom did this without telling the kid
she did this by herself
so how would you even tell the kid like
the kid's like are you cool with this
kid
no i'm not mom what's wrong with your
a nasty tweet and then there's creating
deep faces please please don't tell
my schoolmates to go kill themselves and
make these fakes when i would tell my
mum that i was being bullied she wasn't
thrilled about it
yeah she was like you know i'm not happy
about this i'm putting a word to the
teacher but
you're on your own yeah yeah yeah this
is your problem exactly
i can't deal with this [ __ ] i don't even
know what's going on
like i mean [ __ ] hell that's scary i
mean
it's just so many these the parts of
this story is actually insane
yeah that this could happen it is
literally like a horror movie plot
what this is this is kind of like it's
just it's almost too cartoony to be a
black mirror episode
that's what that's what it is it is it's
so like if this was a blackberry episode
you'd be like yeah twist's really
predictable
like really really over the top yeah i
mean like it's like a
great horror film like the mom's kind of
an unbelievable villain here she could
have used more character development
more motivation no
this is reality but what scares me is
that
like what what does this mean for the
future of deep fakes now because like
uh this week especially this new apps
come up where
it's gotten really easy to deflate yeah
you know deflate you know
use use it for memes use it for harmless
memes to make people sing
[ __ ] bakami thai i mean you know
we're used to
you know people doing [ __ ] terrible
photoshops or doing stuff like that so
if someone sent me a video of me doing
something i clearly didn't do or never
ever did i'd be like
i don't give a [ __ ] it's fake right and
i'll say it's fake and yeah that'll
probably be the end of it
but to someone who's never really had
anything online or any kind of like
you know posted anything about
themselves inside like their personal
facebook
i can see why receiving a video that
looks like you
doing something that you didn't do could
be [ __ ] terrible yeah
right absolutely you would think that
wow people are really going to believe
this even though
you know realistically they're probably
not going to you explain that it's fake
right
yeah i mean it's it's gotten to a point
where like for people like us
especially where we show our faces on
camera pretty often
it wouldn't be hard to make a convincing
deep fake with you know us
coming on camera literally every week i
think we all uh we all agree on this
that you do not have permission to make
any deep fakes of us and we don't
condone any of them by the way just
saying that
you're legally not allowed to do that
yeah i mean is there anything legal
that's
you know that yeah you can't you're not
like i think legally speaking you can't
like
just do that yeah um depending on what
jurisdiction you're in
yeah tom scott did a video about it
right i think i think the laws around it
but iffy and obviously
stuff like this always takes because
it's such a new thing yeah yeah yeah
it's a really new thing because like you
know i've seen like the buccaneer tie
deep fake someone just like you know
this is
funny meme whatever but then i don't
know how it i would feel if i saw the
uh you know the ksi ainsley harrier deep
fake because that's that's so good
that's so good it's funny as [ __ ] but
then
also something at the back of my mind
which makes me
like that's [ __ ] worrying that's how
good like how good it is
and i'm glad it's been used as a funny
meme but
my god if if i saw if i saw my face on
somebody else like that
i would just think damn i'm glad this is
being used
for a funny meme but this could be used
for something that's really luckily
right now
as many deep fake things are being made
there's just as many things that are
detecting if deep fakes have been made
like programs that are being written to
detect them
so right now it's like it's a lot of
software's will detect when the when
it's a deep fake
yeah but whether it'll get to the point
in future that it that it is
do you think like it's only a matter of
time before we get our first deep fake
cancellation
no i think we're quite far away from
that right i think i think they're still
too rough and the technology isn't there
yet but i think it's possible within
like i've seen some defects that are
really [ __ ] convincing though but
like the
the videos are like always in like 480p
max right like and well that's like kind
of the video you'd expect for i don't
know like the
kind of phone quality exposed videos
they're never like
720p 4k it's always like [ __ ]
playstation eye camera
but i think the the more the easier it
gets to cancel someone from a deep fake
the less cancelling will happen because
everyone will be like it's a deep fake
is it a deep fake or everyone's going to
defense is going to be it's a deep fake
yeah all right but like how did that
video of me punching a baby
that's the thing how long until the deep
fake argument is going to be legitimate
yeah yeah well i mean the moment that
you can counsel someone for a deep fake
is when that argument will become valid
right because they'll be like oh i mean
you sure you saw that do you think it
was yeah it was deeply it's a really
good deep faith
looks so real oh my god i can't believe
it myself
our world's going to become a lot more
messy when he gets there unfortunately
but you know
it's uh yeah i mean there's nothing
what's scary is that there's nothing to
stop the technology being out there but
i mean i i guess you can argue this for
a lot of things because i remember
when you know 3d printers became a thing
and then
you can still 3d print guns yeah exactly
you can still 3d print guns you
shouldn't but i mean
you shouldn't and i believe it's illegal
right uh
well it's it's most around it real weird
i think i think i think what it is is
that there's
most uh 3d printing machines can detect
if it's like the blueprint of a gun or
firearm or something and just
not well it's like a photoshop if you
put a picture of the the dollar bill
in uh they won't let you do anything to
it yeah it'll like stop you
oh really yeah i had no idea yeah it's
so they don't want to photoshop it to
like try and like you know
because the software's so powerful
photoshop print out free money yeah
photoshop is really powerful tool yeah
and the stuff that they're constantly
adding to it is just
you know adding to the repertoire of how
strong it is and it's like very
concerning but then again you know
it's like when photoshop first started
as well like we were all like oh my god
people are going to be like it's it's
crazy you know like
everyone's going to start getting
cancelled they're going to be people
going to put nicholas cage in orgies
although that's
i can't remember there being a case
where someone got in trouble for a
photoshop picture
like a big story like because normally
you know a picture at least you know
there needs to be a lot more context
behind why the picture
exists yeah yeah exactly and without
reasonable context of why
the picture would exist people aren't
really gonna believe it yeah i feel like
it's probably gonna be the same for a
video
like if there's a video of like i don't
know like robert downey jr just like i
said like punching a kid
in like a park or something it's gonna
be like well one why is robert down a
junior in a park
why is he playing basketball with the
kid then punching it right this is gonna
be like
the context is gonna be needed like
there's gonna be so many questions
they're gonna need to be answered before
you take a video seriously
i think that's good yeah but but like
how long until you do run into like that
you know
perfect situation where it's like oh the
story is there the narrative is there
everything lines up the only difference
is that robert downey jr didn't actually
punch the kid yeah i mean like but i can
make him punch the kids
yeah he was close i mean i mean [ __ ]
fake news articles are bad enough
already yeah
with with how you know there are [ __ ]
anti-vaxxers and
flat earthers and just things that have
been enabled because it's so easy to
stay in your bubble and
it's really like strengthen your own
argument and you're right it's a
worrying time
it is it is definitely a worrying time
but i don't let it get to me i'm trying
to enjoy life you know
i'm just trying to live my best life the
world may be ending but i'm gonna have a
good time
i still laugh at these memes i care
about what i need to care about
no more that's kind of how i like to do
it like i just think that
after a certain point if you just start
worrying about everything you're just
gonna be [ __ ] miserable
and like i think obviously you know when
it comes to like you know you're voting
on
your politician your area yeah i think
you should care about that and that
should matter but like
beyond that do i care if a news
presenter
in the u.s says like something [ __ ]
abhorrent i'm like no honestly it's not
really my problem and i don't really
give a [ __ ] like
maybe that that's i don't know is that
is that like elitist to think that like
i think it's just
outside of my like like you know i don't
know to me like stuff that goes on the
u.s sometimes i'm like that's honestly
not my problem
like is that bad like so some people say
that's like a
like a prejudiced or ignorant mindset
work it's like
i have the luxury right it depends it
depends on the context right because the
problem is
that the problem with that argument i
feel is that
there's no way a human can care about
absolutely everything
true so at some point you're going to
have to pick and choose
what you care about otherwise one you're
probably going to be a miserable [ __ ]
and two you're gonna wake up and you're
gonna you're just gonna be
exhausted i'm not gonna have to do
anything on the day because you just
feel flooded and i feel flooded enough
with my own social media right now and
like and this is me
like where social media is so
intertwined with our jobs so i see this
stuff and i'm just like i can't care
about it i'm pretty sure that's how
people become nihilists right they just
like they look at the world it's like oh
the world is [ __ ]
i guess nothing matters i mean like it
feels like it's just been so much
like heavier as well i've since the
pandemic as well because yeah yeah
you're just trying to like get by
you know life's already difficult enough
and then shit's going on you're like
[ __ ] man like
i'm i'm literally just trying to be
happy for like 10 seconds here can i
have this yeah i
i kind of feel a bit jealous of our
parents when they only had to care care
about the [ __ ] that was happening around
them
now i have to care about [ __ ] that's
happening halfway across the world yeah
like when i see like you know my my
parents get [ __ ] furious that they
change the bin size of like the council
by like ten percent lower they're like
oh my god this is unreasonable you know
like i just missed the days where i
could give a [ __ ] about stupid [ __ ] like
that yeah yeah
now i've got to worry about like
literally like
cultural engagement nothing to do with
you right yeah it's just like i don't
know man i i
i want to care about everything and i
want to give like people who are
fighting for like legitimate like good
fights i want to help them out but at
the same time it's like there's so much
[ __ ] like [ __ ] going on and obviously
the internet has obviously made
all the information even more accessible
so there's so many more things to care
i'm talking about global warming right
don't waste too much food right what's
going on over here
there's a civil war going on in this
country and like atrocities happen how
do i
how do i like legitimately like give my
energy literally
how to live yeah like that's that's just
life isn't it yeah
like i don't want to be like um global
warming is more important than people
dying in this country yeah i mean it's
like
how where do you where do you draw the
line on where to start well i mean i
think you can like
you know pick and choose what you care
about but it's the difference between
being publicly open about this stuff
right it's like yo i mean i wouldn't say
i don't care about something as much or
as like yeah it's oh my god this is so
tough to talk yeah i mean
it is it literally makes you sound like
an [ __ ] yeah you don't give a [ __ ]
about
like what do you think
you're our manager we are we going to
get cancelled for this mailing but no no
but no i i totally understand because
i feel like that's just part of being
human right you know there's
going to be people that's you know make
the argument well you're privileged
enough that you don't
have to care about it right but i i
would argue that
surely surely you can't you also
can't care about every single issue
happening in the world because you you
feel strongly about this one issue
because it definitely affects you and i
understand that but surely that means
that you can't put the energy into
caring about another issue i don't think
there's i don't think there's
any person out there living any type of
life pre like you know
uh prejudice or not prejudiced
privileged or not
who can dead ass be in a position where
it's like right now
everything in the world i need to worry
about because it's important to me like
yeah it doesn't matter who you are like
there's going to be one piece of news
where you're just like that has nothing
to do with anything that resonates with
you
yeah that like that you really believe
in yeah and that you fight towards like
helping that like i'm i'm down with that
yeah
yeah at least you're fighting towards
something it's better than someone just
getting up in the morning being like i
don't care about any of this [ __ ]
yeah i mean like it's it's it doesn't
really bother me much when people get
like angry about
you know like oh my god you don't care
about this but i hate people who are
like you don't care enough
about this specific thing yeah like you
should be so angry about this thing and
i'm like
man i'm literally just trying to get by
yeah like what dictates like the
quantitative worth of how much you care
about some people who get willing to get
like outraged and like really
like a lot of fire up their ass for
something you know and like i don't you
know obviously
we need we need people like that yeah of
course yeah although [ __ ] doesn't get
done i can't expect any everyone to be
like yeah but then
i hate it when i see people like
blackmailing other people being like you
should count more you should care
so much more about it because because
the problem with the argument is that
there's no way to frame it without the
person
without the person who you know cares
less about the topic
there's no way to frame the argument
without making them making them
like look good you know because it's
just okay you don't care about it
therefore you are the [ __ ] because
you don't care about this important
issue
and i feel like can we just accept that
we are all human
you know we why we are all just trying
to get by everyone has different issues
some matter more than others but it's
it's
it's a lack of empathy you know we
in order to empathize with your problem
you at least have to
give us some empathy as well you know
and i feel like there's there's
just there's just like a lack of empathy
in that sense and that kind of argument
i'd like to think about being ignorant
on any of this that you know it won't
result in [ __ ] let's cancel the boys
but
i mean just let me know down below i'll
i will read the comments so if i am
missing any like big point here
or i'm being ignorant please do let me
know because i would like to judge my
mindset i don't think it's
i don't think it's ignorance personally
i think it's just like being honest
yeah yeah i mean i'm exactly the same i
try to keep it as open-minded as
possible
about everything um and i've you know
i've definitely changed my viewpoints on
certain topics thanks to what people
have said about what they've been
discussing of course there's words i
like there was one person who um
because i think uh uh someone tweeted me
was like connor
shouldn't say the word crackhead is like
a descriptive word
it's a bad word uh because it apparently
has to do with a lot of
um you know like racial stereotyping
back in the war on drugs in america and
stuff and is used as a derogatory term
so i just stopped saying it
that was because someone tweeted at me
saying stop saying it i was like well i
don't really need this word
like you know because i said it on the
podcast and you know i realize
afterwards i'm like
yeah i mean there's like way better ways
to describe that
what i was trying to that feeling i was
trying to get across without using that
and i'm like yeah i don't really need to
use that word i haven't said it since on
like podcast or anything so i'm like oh
i haven't said it ever and i just don't
feel the need to and i'm like cool
thanks for letting me know
commented like if i have a bad habit let
me know i'll try and get rid of it yeah
yeah
uh if you're like connor you're fat [ __ ]
you i'm working on it
other things okay now the ones i hate
the most are connie you're fatter
it's like wow thanks
[Music]
that's always rough because that's like
oh my god yeah i always feel bad for
people whether
it's in that situation it's rough but
comments comments be brutal sometimes
comments really do pick apart like
everything yeah yeah but it's cool
though because sometimes you miss
something
yeah exactly it i i feel like having a
good balance is the healthy thing
because
um you have to find this balance between
knowing that you can't please
everyone um and finding a balance
between okay this this
this person's making a legitimate point
i i can change my behavior
because you know he yeah they they're
making a sound argument and i completely
understand i mean the comment section
full of yes men is just
kind of boring isn't it well i mean you
know people have their
you know when i read comments about
trash takes i'll be like i [ __ ] hate
joe or i [ __ ] hate connor yeah right
and i'm like well i mean i get it right
because it's like i guess to outside
like characters that's fine it's all
good dude
you've got your favorite i get it it's
all good dude
[Music]
yeah i don't know it's it's but then
sometimes they go a little too far with
it like man i wish connor would [ __ ]
quit the podcast
i'm sorry that's not gonna happen
anytime it's not gonna happen but like
if it did do you really
do you think everyone wants that like i
don't know there are some that are just
like man i wish connor would just
deck gaunt in the faces i'm just like i
will off camera
and i was like man is this is this how
friends act you know at least wait till
the trash tastes special where we
like to have a boxing match or something
right not that we have anything planned
and that was just me
boxing confirmed i'd actually like
ironically
love to be like a youtuber boxing match
because i just think like one
mailing's like getting ideas right now
it's like multi-million dollar day
i wish i could bring in
multi-millionaire i i don't know because
like
one you get an excuse to train you could
probably hire a personal coach you know
yeah i'd probably get in mad shape for
that and it would probably be fun i
guess i'll play the villain i'd love
that that'd be so much fun
but who would i fight though you know
that's the thing right yeah i haven't
got any enemies
so i should start beef with someone now
stop flexing
what do you want is not having enemies
like something to brag about like man
conor doesn't
god doesn't hate anyone i mean i don't
even ask for enemies and i have enemies
i mean enemies are very strong yeah some
people who dislike me
but like i i don't have any like open
beef with anyone on youtube
right i mean i don't really [ __ ] do
anything i just kind of just
do my own thing i mean there's a
difference between having youtuber beef
and having actual real beef where you
have a big problem with someone yeah
yeah yeah i was like would you what
would you
categorize like the ksi logan paul stuff
would you just you pure youtube b
for like legit that has to be youtube
beef right it was so over the top
i mean i don't like i think they're here
with each other
yeah and i think along the way they
started liking it yeah
i'm pretty sure it started as a
legitimate beef and then they were like
oh
we can make money off we're making tens
of millions of dollars
hold on hold the phone i mean i feel
like the line is blurred
where you have a financial incentive to
have beef oh yeah
yeah if not like
if they're just like [ __ ] talking to
each other see the light bulb light and
and over mailings head right now just
like lighting up bro
she's like she has a pog face right now
they made they made like over like what
twenty thirty million dollars each
yeah like that because it's not it's not
actually beef like personal beef about
anything that
really matters like no one told like one
of their moms to go [ __ ] themselves or
like oh you know
like yeah the insults were dude the
[ __ ] uh the pre-match [ __ ] like beef
like [ __ ] talking things were the best
part of the boxing matches they were
so bad at talking [ __ ] to each other it
was like it was like wrestling well
because yeah
my dad is nintendo yeah he's like my dad
knows
me emotion my dad's goku
and he's got the dream it's just like
yeah watching watching
if you didn't give a [ __ ] about any
youtube boxing it was quite entertaining
as much as uh it was entertaining to
watch like i paid for the pay-per-view
because i'm like you know what
if i if i can if you can make this a
thing on youtube i'm i'm more i
paid for it because i'm just like you
know what you are making entertainment i
i [ __ ] get that i i'm
i'm watching a clown fiesta and i'm
watching to i'm paying to watch the
circus but i'll pay to watch the circus
you know
no and i i want more of this i think
this is great for youtube and also
for boxing it did like wonders yeah and
it was like it's like the whole
the renaissance of boxing right now well
i mean for like the people in our age
my dad loves boxing and my dad's age
bracket love boxing
yeah they they love it but like you know
under under 30 and i think
mid 30s i don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
about boxing yeah a lot of people don't
i mean i'm sure there is a
there's a good there's a good segment of
people who probably love boxing and mma
and all that yeah but it wasn't like
nearly as popular as it used to be with
our age group at least yeah
yeah because boxing was like you know
some of the most classic moments in
sports in
our boxing matches like anything like
rumble in the jungle you know anything
with muhammad iconic
[ __ ] iconic to this day and you know
i i grew up in an era where
i didn't even watch any boxing match i
don't think i don't i didn't watch
boxing i think i've ever sat down and
watched a boxing
match in my life i i would just my dad
loved watching it and he'd be like man
this guy's fighting this guy for the
world heavyweight and i'm like who are
these two people
no no because if you're a kid and your
parents weren't into it then how the
[ __ ] can you
afford to watch the pay-per-view yeah
right like there's no way you could
watch it it's always an american time so
it's always that like
3 a.m like sky which is already like 40
pounds a month and you pay an extra 20
pounds on top to get the pay-per-view
yeah yeah it's just yeah crazy yeah i
mean
i i don't know it's like uh what do you
think about the whole i don't know this
is changing gears too fast but uh we
think about the whole
thing where everyone's like man they're
they're ruining like boxing
by bringing in these influences to it
because it's happened with chess as well
uh by bringing in these like
non-traditions where you bring in like
you know you kind of i guess
the way they would argue is that you're
diluting like the sport right
like i don't unders i don't understand
how
putting more eyes onto a sport ruins it
yeah because the whole point
of keeping a sport alive is that
a sport is kept alive by how many
viewers watch it
yeah i mean there's there's a side of it
where i can understand
like you know for chess like at least
you know what if you start at age 12
right and then you're like you're like
30 now you're a grandmaster you've
literally been playing your whole life
for chess right yeah you're about to
like this is your time to shine
and then [ __ ] pogchamps has like you
know
20 30 times more viewers than anything
you ever will get
i i could i could understand why they're
mad yeah right that just sounds like
that just sounds like a villain
protagonist to some sports animals i
understand
i've been in backstory to some sport
it's super easy to understand
why they would get mad but then you know
if you like anyone it's like a youtube
video right if i make a youtube video
and i'm a small youtuber
right about um about this mike wazowski
figure
right right and then gone you know who
has
you know a million uh let's say gonna
say ghana's three million right and a
youtuber ten thousand makes a video
about mike wazowski and god pretty much
does like nearly a one for one video
you know but in god's style right yes
that guy will be angry he's like god
just made my video but to a bigger
audience he's gonna get all the views
what you're not seeing is a huge kick
that you're gonna get a bunch of
trickle-down views yeah of course and
that's what's gonna happen
with all the stuff is that yeah you're
gonna see the immediate results of
you know getting uh the trickle-down
effect from all these massive events
with like
normies if you will right but they but i
think the problem is that most of these
like
quote-unquote purists don't see it as a
trickle-down effect they just no no i
don't know
they see it as like sloppy seconds right
well yeah they see it as like you're
ruining the sanctity of my sport it's
like i wanted all the guys to come to me
first
yeah yeah yeah but you know it's you
know again more eyes more sponsor money
it's all good yeah i mean like i think
we talked about this like two weeks ago
where you have to evolve with the times
right
and there's got that you have to have do
you have to find a way to garner
interest in your sport
it's like keep up or get left behind
yeah i mean you know sports like boxing
and chess are
lucky that they've been they've had such
a good history and a good legacy where
that has like kind of carried them a bit
in the modern age yeah where they have
like a solid fan base
yeah but obviously you know if they want
to modernize to a point where they want
to get
bring in a bunch of new viewers you got
to mix it up and chass is having like a
massive renaissance now yeah yeah yeah
i'm happy for chess like chess streamers
the biggest ones are yeah hey cara is
pulling in like plus 25k i think a
stream
uh like and a bunch of the other bigger
ones pulling in like over 5k
viewers on twitch and it's not like you
know just because you're like pulling
new viewers i feel like
that doesn't like dilute you know the
history that has already been built
like people are still going to look back
to like the greats of the times yeah
once they get all the greats people just
people just don't like that they're not
the ones that are solely being talked
about right
i mean i i think one of one of the big
things is that i think
i don't know i might be talking out my
ass but it seems like
like a lot of the younger generations
are less there's less of a focus
on sports and more people are like
getting into like video games and stuff
like that like we literally talked about
how uh my nephew got bullied because he
wanted to play sports but everyone was
playing fortnite whereas when i was
growing up
yeah it was the other way around the
cool kids were playing sport and that's
why sports
had such like so many eyes in it and now
i think because
less kids might be interested in sports
you know
you have to find a new way to appeal to
a young audience otherwise
they're just not going to give a [ __ ] at
the end of the day this is going to
sound weird
but i think that video games are now
more accessible than sports yeah yeah
and i think
why they're doing better like if you
want to play a game of rugby or football
you need what like at least five aside
you need a lot of people to get that
done you gotta get out and a lot of
space yeah a lot of space right like
anyone can play a video game on their
smartphone or whatever anyone
anyone can download channels yeah like
it's like
you know a lot of the sports like i love
i love swimming but like
finding a swimming pool in japan is so
hot yeah without paying out the ass
right yeah and there's not one anywhere
near us and like i don't i don't [ __ ]
know where to go
i mean there's one there's like gyms
that have them but you have to pay like
150 bucks a month to access them yeah
most sports that i
liked as a kid i realized how lucky i
was that there was like in the uk you
have so many
sports centers all around where you can
do this but now i'm like fine it's
so hard to do the sports that i want to
do and get into it yeah i want to get
back into sports and get like a newer
generation into them because it's like
i mean i'm not being funny how are you
going to convince a kid to go you know
play golf when he can play mario golf
it's so accessible
so easy like and the problem is golf
looks so boring
i'm sorry but golf like i i cannot there
are some sports where i'm just like i do
not understand how people can watch this
and be entertained because
i've like i've played golf before um
because like i
um i used to like live kind of near
driving range and it's just so
i you know had a period where i i just
really enjoyed playing golf it was
really satisfying to like smack the ball
um i wasn't rich enough to afford my own
golf club so
you know i had another barrier to entry
yeah yeah yeah it's like that's not a
barrier to entry but
it's really fun to play golf my god it's
so boring to watch
i cannot watch a golf game i mean i'm
sure the people who are watching this
who love watching golf and i'm sorry
disappointing
but there's like there's so many sports
like that though like i used to play
tennis
like a lot i can but i cannot sit down
and watch a tennis match oh i don't know
i can
sometimes some games but they all long
they are live
but it's so but i find it just so weird
and interesting how like
i can i myself love playing the sport
and yet i can't bear to sit down and
watch the sport
yeah like you'd think if someone played
the sport they would be
just as interested to watch it as well
right because they're not always because
the inverse is also true as well where i
might like
have no interest in playing the sport
but i love watching it oh yeah but like
that's good
yeah like me with league is that a sport
but uh yeah i mean like for example i
don't know there's there's always going
to be like massive sports like football
oh yeah uh which that's not going to go
away that's like too deeply ingrained
but
i feel like that that's why the olympics
is so weird to me right
because you end up watching a load of
these sports which
you would in any other circumstances
have no interest in watching but
yeah it's the olympics you know does
anyone want to watch like men's
volleyball
anyone you know i never gave a [ __ ]
about archery until i watched
there are a lot of it that are
interesting when you have them or you
experience them
once every four years oh yeah yeah
they're and your country's kind of in
the race right cause you've got a little
you've got
you've got a horse to root for right
yeah you know
i don't think uh archery week by week
monday night archery you know
like you know you've got to build your
little story lines you've got to build
up yeah the olympics definitely opened
my eyes to like some sports being
really fun i never [ __ ] saw him oh my
god curling and
i never thought i'd be into it but i was
like you know what
this this is hype as [ __ ] i don't know
why curling is like a mario party game
that actually
got turned into a realtor it's like a
mini game but like every round is
curling literally like by accident
like let's just [ __ ] make it real
yeah
that's one sport i really want to play
like try out is there like a sport that
you've never done that you want to try
uh speed ice skating looks so cool
there was um that's that's that seems so
dangerous i thought about that because
there was uh somebody watching
reached out to me on twitter and i was
like because they were verified and
they're like 1 000 followers
and they were they were on like yeah
they were a pro ice skater and like
america canada yeah yeah i love trash
taste they were on the olympic team
oh wow wow like ice skating and they
watch us i think i think
ice skating is real cool real cool
teach me i love ice skating i'd love to
like go fast and do it but i mean yeah
that's too dangerous
yeah i slammed my face i'd have to like
get past that mental barrier of just
like you know you know when you reach a
certain speed and
especially if you're not used to it you
have to get past that barrier i'm just
like i'm going a bit
too fast now if i fall it's really gonna
hurt
i want you know what olympic sport i
want to exist but will never exist it's
like you know the
when you go to like round one here and
you get the the zorb ball
it's like football where you're wearing
like this is the ball where you can
run into each other that'd be such a fun
olympic sport
people on the field [ __ ] just [ __ ]
crazy honestly like if you ever come to
japan come to round one because most
round one have this
you're going to see you're going to see
another sports
yeah yeah so you're gonna see it on
screen now this is this you can easily
get access to this
um yeah they're everywhere and then a
lot of round ones in japan yeah they're
like
bb gun shooting yeah yeah it's
surprisingly because
we i remember when we did it right in
the [ __ ] summer which was a
[ __ ] stupid move right right after we
had like the biggest bowl of curry
so we were like we were in the [ __ ]
sword balls just like rolling around
which is like
oh i'm going to throw up it's
surprisingly uh
it was back there we haven't been there
in so long yeah it was surprisingly
[ __ ] tiring to do that though oh yeah
yeah like
it looks it looks really light to just
run around no it's not
it is it's kind of like playing a mario
party game right because like
it feels like you're because you're
playing football but it's got this like
really janky physics engine
it's like trying to drive a car and like
cyberpunk or something like that custom
game mode
it's like big head mode where you're
i love that to be a sport are you guys
gonna go watch any of the olympic sports
if it happens what the [ __ ] do i apply
no well no supposedly now that like i
think it's being confirmed that
they're not going to bring any
foreigners in right so but you can go
see it at the stadium which means
there's going to be way more available
seats for the actual olympics
i kind of want to do it just because
like do you know how to get tickets
i'm going to look into it i have no idea
because like if i can find it out then
i'd want to go just to say i've been
right yeah the only time i've ever seen
tickets available the only way you could
win it was by buying something from
panasonic and you get entered into a
lottery
yeah which which of maybe you'll get the
right to buy it yeah that's that sounds
like a very japanese
japanese thing to do i don't want to buy
panasonic i want a ticket to the
olympics
because this would be the second time
that i've lived in a city
where the olympics was held because i
was there for london
you went there in london i was in wales
at that time oh yeah so i was like yeah
i was living in london at the time and
uh
yeah i mean i when
during the normal olympics things just
like get super super busy
and i don't really like crowds that much
anyway
so go like i didn't want to go through
the hassle of going through it to a
sporting event and
i don't know i i didn't care enough
about the sport
for me to want to go to this big
sporting event where i you know i just
i literally just said the olympics is
where you watch sports you normally
don't care about but
right you watch it because it's the
olympics right um
so i don't even know what sport i would
want to watch like
would you just
but it's like a bad game like it's a bad
matchup it's like a stomp it'll be like
america versus like
venezuela and basketball like it's like
oh i mean yeah come on obviously
venezuela is going to cry
no i feel like i don't know with those
kinds of stuff i feel it's just you go
to just enjoy the atmosphere you know
because like i remember
have you been i've never been to the
olympics but how would you know that
feels good
well because well i mean every other
sporting event i've been to
because like i remember i went to go
watch uh like but like japanese
atmosphere though in a crowd
they're not very rowdy are they yeah
that's not true
i went to go see the baseball here and
it was really really fun i mean it was a
[ __ ] game
really what was fun about it i i i say
this
having been to a baseball game in the us
and uh i kind of found it a bit boring
oh really
oh okay you don't love the kiss cam gone
what
what i feel okay okay this might be
biased because i i actually quite enjoy
watching the baseball everything but i
also don't enjoy cricket either
right now i'm just making i'm just
making an enemy of like the us
australia india now who where who who
else wanted to do all the sports
they all suck well because like i
remember i went to go watch a rugby game
and it's like i'm not huge into the
rugby but
watching robbie games is fun though yeah
yeah on the tv yeah oh i'm in person
yeah oh yeah well i'm like i win i went
to go watch the rugby and it's like it
was a [ __ ] game because our team got
[ __ ] destroyed but i still had a
really fun time just because of the
atmosphere yeah everyone's wrapping up
the crowd
yeah yeah yeah but the baseball was the
same thing as well like my team was
losing but i didn't really give a [ __ ]
because it was just
i don't know it's just fun you know
cause like how how we had fun was just
getting
very very drunk
and like everyone was just very drunk
and it was just like i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on i'm having a good
i'm having a good time now though
because i'm pretty drunk another
milliliter
i was like yes i'll pay for another
eight dollar hot dog
yeah i don't know i just i just like
having an active component to my sport i
guess i i
i i how can i say this i don't like when
sports are stop starts
you know i i like it to be like so
you're not into like the nfl
or anything like that oh my god bro
watching nfl is hard
the amount of ads they have i'm gonna
get yeah but it's also very stop start
heavy game right
but like i feel like the nfl is like i
can get into the end of nfl because
when the game is in motion that i i've
like
it's hard to find a sport as exciting as
the nfl
when everything is in motion right
winning over our american audience
like because there's so there's so many
things going on in such a short period
of time
whereas you know i look at something
like cricket or baseball
and there's only you know there's yeah
it's very stop stop it's it's very stop
start and
there's you know there's i'm gonna sound
like so i'm so sounds so bad it's just
i just see like a guy trying to hit a
ball you know
what do you prefer american football or
rugby oh it's hard i think rugby i'd
like overall i prefer rugby but i i've
had more exciting
like moments watching american football
um i feel then you would really
enjoy afl what's the afl the australian
football
it's it's like it's basically like nfl
no it's australian if we're representing
our own country i have to talk about afl
because someone's going to talk about it
but afl is basically like it's it's like
it's australian football but think of
nfl but if it was just one continuous
play that never stopped
right okay that sounds pretty fun and
it's like
twice the field size as well okay it's
exhausting it's [ __ ] exciting
afl players are legitimate athletes like
they how do they do that in australia
as opposed to like every other sport i
think i saw something which is like in
an average
afl game a player can run upwards of
like 20 kilometers
[ __ ] for like well for and it's and it's
a two-hour game
[ __ ] oh my god and a split but they
split i bet they made that game that
long on how long
australians need to drink yeah
that's why afl games are the best to
watch at home because it's like two
hours of drinking [ __ ] it
30 minute recess you know it's good it's
perfect yeah but i think you'd really
like if you don't like the start stop
aspect of
nfl i think you'd really like because i
do i really like a lot of
sports where like there's a lot of
things in motion you know oh yeah love
football love watching basketball
i when i went to canada i loved watching
uh the hockey
i think i could read against you [ __ ]
fun yeah so
fast-paced that's that's a sport where i
think watching that
like live would be super super fun right
yeah i'd love to watch that like the
atmosphere just sound this looks
super like and in the background it's
like oh this might turn into a fight
exactly right
sadly i've never lived anywhere where
it's like a popular sport
yeah sucks i want to but like every time
i when i went to canada i was like
literally like i was watching it all the
time
yeah it's so funny it's really i want to
go and watch one next time i go canada
america
but yeah i would see i said something
nice about america for once
i got an angry email that was like um
they were like the subject was
please educate yourself on america okay
you talk about america all the time but
you always get everything wrong
in our culture totally incorrect i
should find it i think i deleted it
though because i was like shut the [ __ ]
up
yeah i don't wha what about uh what
about like the sumo
sumo oh i cuz i really want to go watch
the summer i think that would be fun to
watch yeah i i don't watch enough sumo
to have an opinion or i haven't tried to
watch enough zoomer to have an opinion
you know someone in the someone in my
twitch chat notified me that there's a
twitch channel that streams the sumo
really yeah with english commentary oh
my god so like every now and then when
it's on i just kind of flick it on leave
it in the background while i'm working
because i'm just like
[ __ ] like don't even have to turn my tv
on it's on twitch that's [ __ ] great
have you ever like gotten into a sport
or something because of a show you
watched or an anime
or something like that because like the
only reason i gave the nfl a chance was
because of [ __ ] eye shield and i hate
i sound like such a weeb for saying this
that i'm just like
okay i'm gonna give an nfl i'm gonna
give the nfl a chance
mine's even worse i got into tennis
because of prince of tennis
hey hey i got into like cycling from
yomushi did you actually yeah
okay i found the email all right hey
khan i love the podcast but if you
if you could do me and the rest of
american fans a favor
could you please stop throwing
misconceptions around about us
maybe educate yourself a little bit and
how we do things here instead of
believing the typical stereotypes
it's almost every podcast now you say
something about america that's
completely false so it only applies to
one percent of us that is
and it's just annoying like what i don't
know i wish they gave examples so i
could be like okay it's fair right now
yeah so you can
are we wrong about things most the time
mailing a lot of it
a lot of it's right a lot of it's right
apparently here's the problem with
america right
wait wait go on okay okay well there's
many problems
so right something that applies
to one state does not apply to another
because america is [ __ ]
it's so varied like meline do you not
think of like
you feel very different to other states
right like you don't feel like you have
anything in common with people from like
florida right
yeah so like someone from like i can
relate to someone
from any part of the uk and i can
understand everything i understand how
you live
everything's the same but yeah for like
someone in like california right you
can't possibly relate completely to
someone from like minnesota
no no like it's a team totally different
culture a totally different vibe
shut up maybe like there's so many
because it's so vast there's so many
different like
micro cultures and everything yeah like
definitely like whenever i go
visit sydney's family in milwaukee and
wisconsin
um it's like there's definitely a
midwestern culture
that's oh yeah yeah from traveling the
us
you realize like how different they all
view each other as
like americans yeah it's completely
different it's really interesting yeah
so [ __ ] you
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding he
did he did say he was a big fan of the
foreign sorry
yeah have you guys seen any like obscure
sport that
you like that you've only you only know
about because it's been recommended on
youtube or something
but then like it actually looks pretty
[ __ ] hype ah there was one
i forgot what it was but i think it's
like an indian sport or a
southeast asian sport where it's it's
volleyball
but you kick the ball what the [ __ ]
it's literally just think of volleyball
but like you know how vulnerable you
pass it with your hands yeah
but instead of your hands you kick it
it's not just football tennis
kind of don't say that
every sibling like players like how gay
how do you ruin the sanctity of our
sport
that sounds good like have you seen
stuff like professional tag
and stuff like really skill tag is
[ __ ] awesome like vox did a video
about how it came to be as well
how do you think how did they come
together just a guy who was like really
obsessed with the idea of making like
tag courses
just kept like building them and people
were like yeah this is pretty fun
actually you know what's one excuse what
i really enjoy watching ultimate frisbee
yeah ultimate yeah that's a really
[ __ ] that's really fun well
in the us i think it's quite popular
because like monkus brownlee right plays
it
oh really yeah he plays it is it an
olympic sport it's not is it no no
it's not olympic sport he mentioned it
quite a lot though in his videos and
he's shared videos of him playing it
yeah i guess outside of america it's not
really like a thing i mean i remember
we played it for like sports once for
school and it was really fun yeah i mean
we played it in school as well so it was
definitely a thing but it was more seen
of just as just it sounds like the most
college sport ever yeah
you know what i mean like i am past time
i have the luxury of being able to play
ultimately frisbee
it's the ultimate it's the ultimate that
like
yeah why why ultimately we don't have
ultimate football
yeah we do what what if they called it
like epic frisbee
i'd be playing it right now yeah i'd
like to join our epic frisbee team
that's the kind of sports you you'd
think you'd see on twitch or something
right
frisbee i could see the ultimate frisbee
on twitch
why not that'd be [ __ ] awesome like
yeah i mean i feel like twitch would be
the perfect platform for a lot of these
more obscure sports like
professional arm wrestling as well have
you seen that that's like the most
dude bro sport i've ever seen right
that's like the slapping slapping
yeah yeah most critical love to
commentate on like what i love what i
love about watching professional uh
professional arm wrestling is is it is
that like they're
egging each other on to do better right
it's it's almost like it's almost like a
gym session was like
you got this bro no no you got this bro
ah
actually you know the best one is i
decided this is the best one the best
sport you've seen on the internet three
times forget about but remember there's
badass
yeah it's the like sumo but with the
like the the
like robot wars oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
like sumo it's a sumo ring with like
where they have like mini robots and
they have to push each other out and
it's from where the on my own machine
there is
yeah it's like the what was that show
it's in japan wars i think
no but america did a version of it
i think that clip is from a japanese
it's from the japanese one where they do
it with miniature ones because the
battle bots and robot wars in the uk
were like [ __ ]
giant yeah yeah yeah like these ones are
like tabletop well
yeah it's something to destroy it's
supposed to push the other thing out
that's really cool it's really [ __ ]
cool there's nothing getting destroyed i
am not
interested my man monkey brain not happy
no destruction
i mean i i kind of miss robot wars i
don't know i don't know
when it got cancelled is it still a
thing it's probably not silly i don't
think that's right
i don't think battle boxes are the sort
of thing either male 1 check that out
yeah it's
one it's one of the few things we had
growing up with that made engineering
look cool
right because because it's really hard
to make engineering look cool
right but you you see you see these like
mechanics that would be
like a really cool way to teach
engineering coding
like an all-in-one thing yeah get them
to make just a little thing [ __ ] move
around a little bit like why not teach
this
the one thing i loved about uh
battlebots though was just like
just just the fluctuation between like
the different people
that who clearly had completely
different skills in engineering like one
robot was like
this robot is an automated arm that can
you know grab and pick up robots
and then there's another dude's like the
challenger comes in it's like i
attached 60 knives onto this point and
the only function he can do is go
forwards and backwards saw on wheels
yeah that's literally it like it's so
funny
and you see like some like piddly robots
that had like the most
depressing flipper of all time i
couldn't even flip my grandma
and then it goes up against like [ __ ]
hypno disc or something it just gets
absolutely destroyed half of them like
don't even move like
in practice so it's just like it's just
the door stopper on wheels
and then like i don't know if battlebots
had this but the uk one had this where
like
the the show runners had their own like
ops
robots oh yeah yeah that would just like
when the nothing was happening
they'd be like send out charles or
something like that sir kill a lot yeah
and they're like
this just [ __ ] massive clearly like
absolutely god to your engineering world
created
coming back
i'm just getting reminded of all like
these old television shows i used to
watch as a kid now
remember gladiators was that was that
part of that's very
very old that's very very that's like
90. that sounds really familiar what is
that
it's basically like very much inspired
like
the whole like kind of sporty-esque like
really intense
physical sport yeah it's it's it was
kind of like instead of
like instead of like uh what what's
what are like the shows that like four
guys and stuff is based around
wipeout wipe out so instead of like
going against an obstacle course you'd
have an obstacle course
but then you'd be competing against a
gladiator which was like this kind of
like
really fit muscular person and it that
would have there would be this
competitive element where you'd have to
beat
like beat this person like this yeah on
on this obstacle course or something
like that
or you'd have to just like literally
fight them yeah
that's the final turtle basically you
get to the end he's just standing there
i mean i the best way i can describe it
it's basically something very
it's like wipeouts with uh with
wrestling basically
anyway so it's like so it's like real
time like you're fighting
like or not fighting but like with the
glasses there's like one i think there's
one event in it where like you both had
like the
those like long poles with like cushions
on the end
and
the platform yeah i remember that i mean
i know that sure is old because then
like i think when i was watching that
like very early 2000s everyone's wearing
like latex and spandex and i'm like oh
yeah i'm pretty sure all that's just
taken from takeshi's castle right
yeah what's the other one the japanese
one's called like uh i think it was it's
called like um
ultimate banzuki or something oh yeah
yeah i think well like literally they
will do so this is this show is so fun
you should watch clips on youtube it's
really [ __ ] cool so what they would
do is right is that they would have like
someone either they would be a generic
thing or they'd have an expert so they'd
bring on like
10 expert pogo people and they would
build like a [ __ ] impossible
pogo obstacle course right and they
would have to do it and like the [ __ ]
they would do is insane
yeah and it was always it wasn't just
general people it's like no they get
professionals
and there'd be people who like they'd
have to be um they'd bring people who
are professionals
like handstands yeah and i'd have to do
a whole course
handstand walking around like going
upstairs going on wobble yeah i've
definitely seen it like
it's really [ __ ] cool you should
watch this just type it in i think it's
i have to oh
my goodness i think it's cool something
like that yeah
and like the stuff they'd have to do was
crazy like they had that um
you know that mario party game where you
have to like there's like seven things
stacked like have a hammer and hit it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they did a game where two people had to
do that i need to like get it they just
hit them all
out right but obviously when they hit it
yeah they would like tip the thing over
yeah it was really cool
that's based off like a traditional
japanese like toy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really cool
what's like the best concept of the
like like a like reality tv program that
you've seen
like physical like game show challenge
anything like ninja warrior
like the original the japanese original
sasuke yeah yeah that's really good
there's this really old uh reality tv
show that channel 4 made
i can't remember the name because it was
like a one-off series right but i always
remember it because
i thought the concept was genius because
what they did
is this was this was way back when when
big brother was like a massive thing
but the twist was they took they took
these group of people right
um that uh weren't exactly the brightest
brightest bunch of people but you know
wanted to be on a reality tv show
and they would basically they basically
convinced them that they were going to
go to space
right oh i think i remember this so what
so what happens is they they literally
go
they literally like take them astronaut
training right right
and make them go through all the
training but also feed them like a bit
of fake information right
because they had they had this real mock
spaceship
um and they taught them that you know we
we we're using new technology where
it doesn't require rockets it's kind of
like an airplane where like slowly
circles up to the earth's atmosphere
these guys would believe it right and
they thought they thought they were like
being trained in russia
what's the name of the show i can't
remember i'm gonna have to look it up
because
it was a genius show um and like at any
point
if like at any point one of them could
have found out right because they were
they were
um the t the producers said you know
you're gonna be trained in russia
it's not gonna be in england and what
happened is they just took them on a
plane and just like
circled round and just landed in a
landed in like a abandoned airfield in
surrey or something like that
so they were just like in the middle of
england they were thinking they were
going to space
and they actually took some of these
people and just
uh have you ever been on like one of
those fake roller coaster rides
where where where it's like it's kind of
like the 4d ones yeah like the 4d ones
where where you know you just
you just you just kind of like have this
spaceship that just kind of turns
out it's cool yeah it's called space
cadets
yeah it aired in 2005 on channel 4. yeah
yeah channel 4 normally does all the
really bizarre
really unique game shows yeah okay if if
if you got like
if you got some time you want to kill
that's honestly it was such a good
concept and it was a one-off as well
one off season um it was just hilarious
it was [ __ ] hilarious
highly recommend it yeah the first thing
that comes up when you google it is like
controversies
that's been quite controversial i guess
so but i want to watch that now
yeah that sounds really funny yeah that
was like this did the uk has some really
unique game shows
basically there's a game show in the uk
um i think it was literally called
hunted
and they would have like i think six
pairs
or ten pairs something around that and
basically what they would do is they
were like
all right you have like one day and then
we're gonna start trying to
like track you if you're a fugitive all
right so like any of your if you use
your phone
if you use your phone if you do anything
you make calls you go to places like
they'll find you
and so some people were really good at
it and some people were terrible at it
and like yeah and then they had to
survive
two weeks yeah two weeks later two weeks
and then go to a
location to get like a plane to like to
escape
right right and uh yeah what one one
team did win
that sounds really fun it was really
cool it was really it was really popular
the first season and the second season
i think was a bit [ __ ] yeah and
didn't do too well yeah
i feel that's a concept like at first
that would be like wow that's cool but
then i feel it get
old quite fast yeah because there's so
much there's only so much you can do
once you know the formula and once you
know the secrets like just something
like the the
logistics behind that must have been
like crazy
yeah like i wonder how much of that was
faked though as well because
you surely can't have access to all the
like
the police forces like yeah credibility
right because it's just a waste of
police time and services right that's
just a lot of government
hold on wait we gotta find the fake one
you know what i mean
i wonder but in a concept really cool
yeah yeah
was that on channel four as well that
was on channel four as well channel four
makes some good like one-off reality i'm
surprised i've never heard of any of
these
yeah channel 4 makes really good tv
shows in general yeah like some of my
favorite are definitely like some of the
darren brown specials i don't know how
famous darren brown
is outside of the uk right now i'm
probably not so much i've never heard
darren brown oh my god
some of the [ __ ] this man did was crazy
oh my so his favorite thing that he's
ever done so dan brown is a magician
from the uk
he's he's he's a magician that
himself but he's more like a mental
magician mentalist
i'm not even like it's [ __ ] i'm
talking about the word mentalist this
makes this makes it sound fake
this man is just one of a kind yeah yes
man he's like he's
he's a showman he says like everything i
do is like there's
it's it's like not so much that it's
fake but like it's
there is like magic involved he doesn't
claim to be have special powers or
something like that he just claims to
understand psychology
and plays on that right yeah so there's
this one tv show that he did and it is
literally my favorite and it's so
big brain this whole thing so i i'll
spoil the end of it so i'll warn you i'm
gonna do that but i'll spoil it for you
because it's but
it's still cool either way if you watch
it so what happens is this tv show
starts and you're following this
perspective this one woman and i know
this one
so basically what happens is that um so
the show is is that he
basically he knows which horse is going
to win in these horse races
right so the exact name of the special
is called the system
so the way he markets it is that he has
a system
that can 100 predict which horse is
going to win in a horse race
and so it's like this this middle-aged
woman and you know we follow her
he calls her up he's like listen bet on
this horse go now so she goes and she
bets on it and the cameras are following
her
she bets on it she wins right it's like
oh [ __ ] okay
and then he rings her up again he's like
right now put all of your money
on this horse now then like then a week
later yeah and she puts
she puts all the money on it she wins
again right it's like what the [ __ ] is
how is he doing this
yeah this is legit like whole like this
is a fully legitimate yeah
it's like a public gambling that anyone
can battle right
it's a real horse yeah he gives him the
money doesn't he he gives them a
thousand pounds right
i think i can't remember it's been a
while but i i do
no i don't think he gives him any money
does he know well so anyway
she wins and it happens again and he's
like all right now bet again
all the money on this horse she does it
again and she wins
right and i think it's one more time
he's like all right now this is the
final one bet all of your money on this
again and
she wins and you're like what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah he's literally guessing
and then he reveals right and as the
episode ends that like he's literally
done
like a tournament bracket of like every
single race there's nine horses
so every single race he's literally
found nine people
and told them to bet on the different
horses he's literally gone through and
done like a giant like hundreds of
races so it's like a pyramid so like at
the beginning he started
like thousands of thousands of
contestants and he said
you know um i i you know he didn't
reveal who his identity was he was just
like an
anonymous tip and so you know
part of like a certain amount people won
they got eliminated
he gave him a refund and then he went up
to the next bracket and then he kept
he basically kept enough of a group of
people to make sure there was
at least one point and it's so simple
yeah so cool but when you're following
this story and her perspective it seems
like like literal magic yeah yeah yeah
because all he was trying the message he
was trying to say was
like don't forget about perspective just
because you are winning doesn't mean
that
like doesn't mean like there's a magical
system or something like that
it's it's what to do with probability
that sounds right up my alley dude
he's literally a [ __ ] junior yeah his
shows are amazing and like he did one
where
he's done so many questions like i think
one of my favorite ones is like the ones
where
he actually he actually fakes a zombie
apocalypse
right oh that sounds familiar yeah i
might have seen that yeah yeah
so basically he takes us he takes this
one guy right
um so how he gets people on the special
is that people apply to be on his
specials right
right but he doesn't tell anyone that
they know they he doesn't tell anyone
that they've succeeded right so
he gets thousands and thousands of
applicants and he chooses one out one
out of everyone
so he takes this guy and he puts he
basically
um hypnotizes him so he like passes out
and he wakes up
in this like abandoned hospitals all
right
and you know it's it's basically just
this guy
going through a zombie apocalypse except
the truman show right because they get
everyone around him
to act right as if there's a zombie
apocalypse yeah yeah so this guy
literally believes that there's like a
zombie apocalypse i think this is on i
think this is on netflix as well so you
can actually watch this on there
there's another one where he sees if he
can convince someone to commit murder
jesus like fake murder right he sets up
the situation
that one's not as good as the other ones
but like they all vary in quality but
you're definitely gonna have an
experience like you definitely can't
find anything like it
what's the name of the show again just
type in darren brown daryl darren darren
darren brown but he's he's done a lot of
stuff
live shows are really popular as well
i've been to his live shows actually oh
really it's really it's really good
there's like a lot of psychology things
he basically like manipulates like
perception
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really just
interesting stuff yeah
it gives you a lot of perspective and
you know he he goes in saying you know
no
all of this is just magic you know like
he a lot of them not this is magic right
sorry so you said all of this is magic
so i'm just a [ __ ] magician all right
you guys know me hogwarts diploma right
here
disney
no i thought because like watch watching
his stuff he doesn't pretend to be
he doesn't pretend like he has powers or
something like that it's all showmanship
and that's direction
that british people like it yeah yeah
exactly but that's my favorite type of
musician
magician like uh [ __ ] um
what are the what's the david blind no
not david blaine the the
uh penintella that's what i like about
pen and television oh yeah yeah yeah
we're not [ __ ] magicians we're just
good at what we do yeah yeah yeah it's
just all slider handshake you know
unlike you know [ __ ] like chris angel
who's like he's like yes i am the second
coming of christmas i'm literally
[ __ ]
dying
every now and then i love going back and
watching like chris angel clips on
youtube
just because like i remember back in the
day when i watched like chris angel
being like yeah i split this woman in
half and i was just like oh my god this
man isn't
he's actually a magician he's insane
he's like yes i'm walking on water and
it's totally not
just like see-through [ __ ] plastic
boards on the board
were you were you around when uh david
blaine did that stunt in london where
you were like
listening to the caves yeah staying in
the cage or something for like
how long did he stay in there for like i
remember wasn't it yeah it was a long
time
it was like a month without any food or
something
and i remember just thinking there there
were so many moments
during that month where he just got
[ __ ] [ __ ] on by all like the [ __ ]
chavs and
everything right
because like it was back in the time
when you know england had this
nice prim and proper image to americans
especially and
you just had like these [ __ ] people
like these londoners who were just
chucking paintballs at him and [ __ ] like
this
it felt so bad chaps and laundry a
different breed man
man it man just like as well like when i
saw that
he's like staying in there for 30 days
i'm like why
why like i is the record really worth it
like i get it like the stunt but like is
this
is this is this fun i mean i guess the
fact that we're still talking about it
to this day is worth it right
true all right i guess that's the point
right like i just
lose a month in my life to get a bit of
clout
to be talked about the ultimate
i'm clout chaser kidding this shit's
very impressive you're pretty kelly with
magic
make a frog come out of my ass
[ __ ] out frogs have you seen his ted
talk
uh no he had a ted talk uh like breaking
down how he did one of his stunts
uh which was like how he stayed
underwater and like broke the world
record
yeah yeah yeah and like he was going
through the process
of like they tried a load of different
things like they tried stuffing like
um like an airbag into their stomach to
give them like a breathing tube and that
just not just cheating
yeah that's not just that i just know
it's magic that just ended up horribly
other than they just kind of like tried
a lot of different ways to see if this
was possible
and then he they just like the the
conclusion they came to was just
let's just [ __ ] do it properly so
yeah yeah he's just you know
trained yeah let's just let's just
almost drown myself and uh
that's basically what he did and it's
just like man this is this
this man has just monetized being
[ __ ] mental right yeah
like that he did that and he achieved
that like doesn't
like all the credit to him but my god
you must
it's it's the magic of willpower that's
cool [ __ ] craziest people
that do like the [ __ ] like of
[ __ ] that like you know you have to be a
little bit crazy to be a genius i think
you know what i mean like that i think
that has to be a little bit yeah right
because
i mean what was that quote again is like
a
a genius is just an insane person with
an audience
i don't know who said that quite but
it's a quote
and i just my god yeah i don't know it's
like going back to the caving stuff we
took a few weeks ago right it's like
yeah
like it has to some there's got to be
some dopamine deficiency going on here
that requires you to like need to like
i'm like i have a good meal and i'm like
damn that dopamine hit was good
someone's like someone has like a
7-eleven like no i gotta [ __ ] climb
the building yeah i gotta
i gotta climb this 7-eleven it's get a
hit
you're like what what's going on what's
fear factor
oh fear fact yeah i mean a few factors
didn't have a lot of controversy fear
factor
i mean i've i've seen it's like yeah joe
rogan did it right because like it's
either like you can eat your own
[ __ ] or drink your own pizza it's not
even that bad though it's like i
remember
i remember like i think i saw one
episode or one season where like the
the final gross or whatever the [ __ ] it
was called it was like the worst meal
was um it was a balut
uh philippines okay and it's like i
remember because i when i went to the
philippines for the first time aki was
like do you want to try bullet i'm like
the [ __ ] that it's like it's a duck
fetus it was it was the worst thing they
had on fear factor yeah and i hate it
i'm like
people on fear factor are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm like well get get joey on fair
factor [ __ ] yeah they're so
weird about the fact of being like i'm
like this is delicious what do you want
about it i can just imagine right
someone went to the philippines right
like and then someone
really politely said you know this is
our culture this is what we eat and he's
just licking he's like
i can't wait to put this on for you
people are gonna eat this they're
so weird about that i understand like
you know like eating a cockroach or
something right where it's like this
shouldn't be
eating something that shouldn't be eaten
it isn't really widely eaten by any
culture yeah i kind of like i get it
right like
you know and then there's taking like an
obscure food from like a cultural
background
right and it's like this is disgusting
isn't it
look how vile this is someone's gonna
eat this someone's gonna eat this [ __ ]
meanwhile everyone in the philippines is
like um
filipino audience just like microsoft
what like it's either mcdonald's or this
we're gonna waste
and thai people eat water bugs and i i
don't stand by that [ __ ]
i still haven't forgotten melin i still
have not forgotten
okay you're not gonna like go and be
like mom can i take some water books
back i'm filming fear factor yeah right
this is crazy nobody eats this
sarah has a choice between jumping off a
bridge or eating a bug
she chose to jump what is what is fifth
[ __ ] i've never watched it yeah it's not
you get two choices no am i crazy
uh was it two choices
it's just a show where it's like
contestants basically line up and being
like
you can eat if you eat this then you go
on to the next round and if you survive
the entire round you get a prize money
or something like that right but like
the the food or what you have to do is
like usually considered
gross according to americans right at
least and like vegetables
that kid who's just like all a vein
popping out it's like corner when he has
a [ __ ] on america for 30 minutes
hey i think it's fair [ __ ] game i
don't see me [ __ ] emailing americans
being like
stop making british memes i don't say
the word h shut the [ __ ] up be a little
[ __ ] and take your [ __ ]
we all get mocked okay 2021 um but yeah
fair factor
yeah anyway like spinach
with a [ __ ] celery
celery without hummus
i'm so [ __ ] americans i don't
actually believe this i'm joking this is
a joke this is a bit eat the celery or
take the hummus and go home
no but basically it's like it's like you
have to do something gross or eat
something gross and if you decide to do
it then you move on to the next round if
you don't decide to do it
then you get kicked off and basically
each step it just gets worse and worse
and worse i don't know i might be
talking about
this this is how i remember yeah and
then what's wrong with us one of the
watch people do
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] like this i don't
know
it's entertaining actually i don't know
the flashback to another darren brown
special
okay he did another special as well
which is great where the audience get to
choose whether something bad happened to
the guy or something good happened to
the guy
right so they would follow a guy in his
daily life he obviously said yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and literally the audience every single
time chose bad things
and like one of them was like almost
like his family gets christmas presents
early
or he gets [ __ ] kidnapped and he
literally got kidnapped because the
audience wanted to see him get kidnapped
we're [ __ ] up we are [ __ ] up do you
know what the most [ __ ] up thing about
that special was
so it so it the the special basically
ends right
with you know the audience shows a bad
thing happening like he got kidnapped or
something
and then i think as they were trying to
kidnap him um
he got into a car crash now the car
crashed the car crash was staged the
audience didn't know this right
the car crash was stopped and so the
audience seemed hit by a car
and then it's they just like this
unplanned thing darren brown just walks
off
and then you're just you're just left
seeing like the audience kind of like
[ __ ] like what's
one of the audience members going like
uh excuse me you're not being funny but
like this like it's not our fault yeah
hey no
i can't remember exactly what she says
but she's like excuse me this ain't this
isn't funny
like can you tell us what's going on
like why would you make him go through
this
and it's it's like the lack of
self-awareness and self-irony that you
literally came on a tv show
and he kept voting for bad things to
happen and then something bad thing
happened that wasn't scripted but
because it wasn't scripted suddenly it's
a serious matter right
right yeah it was like really
interesting because it was basically
just like you as the audience does not
care about who is on screen
right you just want to see bad things
happen you know these are people
it's really good because you know it's
staged well because this is what you
think right you think it's all fake or
like or you don't care
it was it was a message about like an
anonymity within like crowds i don't
what's the word i'm looking for
like the hive mind yeah like the hive
mindset right where if you have
anonymity you
responsibility is kind of like taking
off you and you're willing to do
like you want to do things that you
might not do if you know you were the
one responsible
i'm pretty sure i saw like at least four
like
black mirror episodes though i like that
yeah it's yeah
i mean but black mirror sucks now yeah
oh my god it sucks so much
i went downhill real fast yeah yeah yeah
is there anything else you guys want to
bring up or
no watch darren brown i guess it's been
a really strange episode we've talked
about so many things yeah
sped run through stuff today like watch
down brown that's how you gotta honestly
like i need to
you guys out of every british like
you know i like to show sydney some
british tv shows because
i feel like british tv shows people only
know like [ __ ] doctor who
and maybe top gear you know yeah and i'm
just like you know british tv shows
they have some good tv shows and i think
darren brown is one of the best examples
you can get from
just quality tv shows coming out from
england
uh i mean i mean you guys have convinced
me so that's what i'm gonna do i i don't
how can you not hear any of that and be
like yeah i'm not interested like you
know what i mean
it's so interesting because the thing
about tv british tv shows is that they
they like he would make one special
year at at most at most so they'd
obviously been like dwelling on this
idea for like a long time so
like some ideas better than others but
there's no idea that you
hear about and you think that's not
interesting at all yes
isn't it this one special where he
teaches old people to like rob an art
gallery
yeah yeah yeah that was one as well yeah
that's good you should watch that yeah
it was good that was that was a good one
um
i can do that or go watch another
episode of don't tell the bride
daddy wasn't caught what it's called we
didn't know what it's called
oh the show's over now and it's all come
full circle i figured it out don't tell
them don't tell the bride that's what
it's called
that's what it was like i'm saying like
3 000 pound marriage yes i'm like [ __ ]
it yeah okay it was three thousand no it
was three thousand right i think it was
ten thousand i don't know but it's the
the episodes
takes episodes yeah hey look at all
these patrons though yeah
they're pretty cool before we end the
episode i'm gonna find out how much
money it was now
okay all right you do that but thank you
to all our patreons and joey do
do the shout out okay in the meantime if
you want to support the show
then make sure to go over to patreon.com
also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our faces go listen to us on
spotify have you found out what it was
yet
uh i blitzed through that it says um oh
yeah they were giving
uh 12 thousand pounds oh okay
so a bit more than i thought that sounds
about right actually a pretty i knew it
was a division that's a decent amount
that's a decent budget that is that's
not bad that's that's not you can you
can get away with quite a bit for that
and this was like the tv
episode then we didn't even even intend
for it to be
it just kind of like yeah every trash
taste episode as well well we we got to
talk about trash tv
i'm happy i mean oh that's the title
i didn't get to talk about my hatred of
love island but you know whatever it's
[ __ ] come on what does it say yeah it's
garbage
why is everyone watching it then connor
why is it save it for the next episode
alright see you guys have a good one bye
[Music]
you